It's so loud.
Welcome to Spooky's Chopscare Mansion.
Welcome.
Ah, ghost.
I think I will be the spookiest thing here.
I think.
Why am I so small?
Is that better?
I hope you guys enjoy the game.
With my face covering the whole thing.
Much better.
Bigger?
I
am the game.
I am the game.
Bigger?
I think it's as big as I can get.
Anyway.
Welcome.
I've never played this game before.
I'm ready to get jumped out of my pantaloons.
I'm ready.
Stop staring at me with them big ol' eyes.
Smaller.
Once you go big, there ain't going back.
Go big or go home, baby.
Played the original before.
I've never played the original.
I've never played the new one.
I've seen sometimes people playing this game.
So I truly know like nothing about it.
Actually, truly, truly nothing.
Nothing.
Headphone users turn the volume down.
Oh.
Actually, thank you for reminding me.
Because I do want to turn my volume down.
I turned it down a little bit before.
This is nice.
I love how you can turn the jump scares off.
Isn't this a jump scare mansion?
Wait, this is kind of nice.
This is chill.
I like that you can turn off the head bob.
Oh yeah, let's turn that off.
What, should I keep motion blur on or off?
I can't remember what people like more.
Calm before the scare.
Off?
Okay.
That should be good then.
The hell is in the bottom right corner?
What are you...
The scariest thing you'll see all day?
Your nightmare?
Your parasocial demon?
Wait, what is it called?
No, wait, what's that word?
The night demon, the ones that make you not able to move.
What is that called?
What is that?
The paralysis demon?
Oh,
it's the sleep paralysis.
Oh, my god.
Good morning, morning, Minto.
It's my birthday today.
Can I get a spoopy Happy Bob song?
Of course.
Wait, how do I say your name?
Ganymede?
Happy birthday to you.
I hope I said your name right.
If I didn't, I'm so sorry.
But it's your birthday, so it doesn't matter!
Happy birthday to you!
Parallelogram demon.
But yeah, I'm not scared at all.
I miss the old music.
This one makes me want to act up a little bit.
What if this was my house, you know?
Parasocial demon.
She's got such a way with words.
You mean you aren't already?
I'm not even at half my power.
I got something in my eye.
Hold on.
Spooky parenthesis demon.
Are we ready to start the game?
Are you guys ready to get your socks knocked off?
You guys are going to scream so much!
Oh wait, which one do I do?
Karamari Hospital?
Should I just do the regular one?
Renovated version of the original jumpscare mansion?
It's not my socks.
Last thing you see.
Before the end is mint.
Prove me wrong.
And check out six of the twenty!
Can you hold my hand?
Okay.
The mansion?
Mansion?
Okay!
Renovated version of the original jumpscare mansion.
Wow!
This...
This mansion is not big enough for the two of us.
There's something up there.
Make it through 1,000 rooms.
You'd like to realize that the end...
of this fairy tale...
has already been ended.
Is that how it goes?
Anyway, just go.
Oh!
There she goes!
I can do that too!
Watch, watch, watch.
I can do this.
Oh!
Um...
Oh, it pauses me.
Never mind.
So, 1,000 rooms, eh?
Can you do it?
I could if I wanted to, but I don't feel like it right now.
Alright, left or right everybody?
Is that Marceline's sister?
My parasocial demon ghost.
Stop!
Left?
Okay.
That was a test for you guys.
Did you guys jump at my scream?
Left or right?
Well, we went left last time.
Okay.
I think I have a stamina.
Maybe.
Wow.
So lovely.
Room 5, we're already killing it with time.
Oh, I think the...
Okay, I do have stamina.
Okay, that's good to know.
Oh!
What's here?
We can take a little break.
I call the bunk bed...
Oh, there's something over here too.
I ain't afraid of no toast.
I don't think I can interact with these.
I have a bunk bed IRL.
What?
What was that?
Wow, the atmosphere is lovely here.
I'm gonna go to this room.
I call top bunk.
Too late, slowpoke.
I've already called every bunk in the bed.
Wait, why is my...
Why am I doing that?
These Minecraft-looking beds.
Minecraft-looking air bed.
Wow, this place is huge.
Actually, you know what?
I'm kind of glad I'm not a maid for this place.
I would have to clean every single area here.
Can you imagine...
What was that?
Can you imagine?
I would be scrubbing every single little stone.
Oh!
Uh oh.
No!
PNG bones!
The skinny legend died here!
No!
Rip, rip skinny legend.
So far, this has been a breeze.
Spooky scary skeletons and shivers up your spine.
Oh my god, there's more!
Yeah, I could use his bones to cause the fire.
Strike a fire, I mean.
We're not causing a fire.
The stamina goes down real fast.
Oh!
What interesting decor.
Oh, there's more bones!
It's a mirror.
I'm looking mighty fine today.
Little wispy, you know?
Oh!
More bones!
What's that sound?
Is that you?
I think I'm going to keep going.
Ah!
What's that?
Why does it sound so rumbly?
Look at that head.
So cute.
Why is it...
Oh.
At first this place seemed cute.
But I've been here for a few days now and I feel quite parched.
And I'm getting this feeling like I'm being watched or something.
This is not romantic at all!
What's that sound?
Wait, didn't I come from here?
Did I go the wrong way?
No.
Room 23.
So there's notes.
Okay.
Good to know.
Wait, the more I go...
Okay, that sound is disappearing.
Is something...
Is something chasing me?
Not so romantic.
Uh oh.
It's loud again.
Is it the paintings?
It's me?
Oh my god.
I was gonna say the guy in the picture is gone.
Let's go to the right.
It's my tummy.
Um...
What are you talking about?
I ate.
I'm not going to go towards the sound.
I'm going to go in here.
Oh, locked.
Just kidding.
I have to go towards the sound.
P&G bones or lost cookie.
Click or save.
I'll be honest...
Oh, there's a note.
I know something...
I know something is following me, but I feel like I'm prancing through the same rooms over and over.
That's what I just said!
Hopefully, leaving notes as breadcrumbs will prove I'm making progress and reaching some destination.
I just hope I don't run out of ink.
I am dreadfully thirsty.
He's going to start using his blood!
Wait!
He's just like me!
I said that same thing!
I said I think I'm going through this...
Did I go through this room before?
I'm already going crazy!
Get used to that.
Already through room 34.
What is that sound?
I've learned that blood for the blood god.
It's from Warhammer.
Ink.
Not quite quenching my thirst.
Taste is terrible.
Stains are terrible.
I don't think drinking...
It was a very romance...
Why is everything about the romance?
Is this supposed to be like a honeymoon suite?
Or...
Am I supposed to be...
Am I...
Are they chasing me here because I booked the room by myself?
I'm supposed to be with someone lovely?
Or...
This area looks familiar too.
Oh, we can go in.
Oh.
Maybe I should run.
Adventurous romance.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Don't lock me out!
Oh.
We saw this one before.
And this one before.
Oh.
That's a little spooky.
I don't really like that one.
What was that noise?
They're still there.
Hmm.
Learn how to sprint?
I know!
Wait.
Is this different from sprinting?
Is running different?
I found something today to satisfy my unromantic thirst.
I awoke today from a brief faint and found before me a bottle of red wine.
I'm not sure what brand or year.
For there is no label.
All I gather is that it tastes strongly...
Metallic.
Oh, buddy.
I don't think that was wine.
I think you just got a good case of iron.
As long as he thinks it's wine, that's fine.
Right?
But also, wouldn't it, like, taste so horribly?
OK.
We're almost to 50.
Can I go in these now?
Oh!
I hit a save!
You can do it.
We can help.
Papa John's.
That's different from the Papa I know.
Where is my lovely romantic evening?
Down?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What
is happening?
Master!
Miss!
The whole room is an elevator.
Oh no!
She's going down, down and she's rolling around.
I don't think that was wine.
I told you bro!
I warned you about the wine bro!
Bro!
This looks familiar too, this room.
It keeps happening.
You are here.
The rooms are spinning and moving.
I'm getting my cardio in.
Didn't expect a little guy like that though.
Oh!
I'm gonna avoid that.
Spouting, splashing, soaking, innards and just invoking.
Nailing never stops the choking.
Oh!
Oh god!
Wait!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh god!
I don't even touch it though!
This is messed up!
Oh god!
I picked the wrong room!
Why am I so slow in the beginning?
No!
Oh god!
They're still coming.
I picked the wrong room!
Don't look back, okay?
Oh!
Oh shoot!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die here!
Don't come at me!
This way!
Don't be locked!
They don't stop coming and they don't stop...
I have a question.
Is this all randomly generated or is there like kind of a...
A pumpkin!
Is there kind of a rhyme or reason?
Am I good now?
Yes.
Do what?
Are they still coming?
Maybe not.
It's random.
Sort of random but not really.
So many bones.
It's a roguelike.
Oh that's so fun!
No notes though.
Every X levels has certain theme floors.
Okay.
Very cool.
Nothing here.
Can you fight?
I don't think so.
Oh!
This is fun!
Let's go this way.
This is actually kind of romantic.
I don't know what he's talking about.
I feel.
I needed a fun stream today.
Good morning.
Good morning!
He's still in the same spot.
We have a new guy!
Look at him.
Boingo.
Let's keep going.
Are they still locked?
Oh!
Fancy.
Toy horse or banana?
It looked like a banana like he was eating.
But a big old banana to me.
Yeah I think this is actually quite romantic.
Nothing else I would want...
Oh shoot.
No please.
No no.
I changed my mind!
This is everybody's fault!
This is not romantic at all!
No!
Oh my God.
What is this?
Oh I didn't go the wrong way!
Ah!
No!
This isn't romantic!
Wait did I go the wrong way?
Please tell me no.
I didn't go the wrong way!
I went the right way!
Please.
Let me through.
Leave me alone!
Why are you guys so obsessed with me?
Ah!
Oh my God.
This...
These goo pile.
I swear.
Run run run.
Run run.
Ah!
That one looked like me.
Um.
I will take my royalties now.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Legally distinct Minto.
Oh.
Nicolas Cage.
Better ingredients, better pizza... oh pasta.
Sorry.
I think my cat sees a bird.
Her tail's going a little crazy.
Better ingredients, better pasta.
That's the power of the Home Depot.
Whew!
Oh.
They're in your head.
They truly...
I just said it instinctually.
Keep a little pep in your step.
Oh, this place is cute.
I have always found the Windows 95 3D maze screensaver romantic.
Yes!
You the real MVP.
I can't believe I did that in first try.
I can't believe I figured out... or rather I went the right ways and I didn't even know it.
Best worst way to spend my birthday.
What?
No!
Fake smiley!
What do you mean the best worst way?
What do you mean?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear smiley.
Happy birthday.
Okay, let's go.
I feel like I could be a little jump scare in this.
ViviCore, thanks for the 10 gifted.
What's this say?
I don't know how much longer I could go on.
I haven't seen any of my previous notes.
So that means either I'm getting somewhere or someone is taking them.
What kind of monster will we approach?
Will we...
See this time?
I feel like I'm in Indiana Jones.
I like this.
Oh, what's that?
What's wrong?
What's happening?
But there's a note here.
That was such a surprise that there would be another entry.
Another actual entry.
One I could admire.
Then suddenly as I came it left and now you disband.
Your influence and inspiration will never leave me.
What is it?
Oh, okay.
Well, I actually can't go through any of these.
Maybe.
Is it gone?
No!
Huh?
No...
No!
No.
Uh...
No!
Uh?
No.
Nrgh!
Ah...
A...
EMPT!
No!
Do I go back?
No.
Read no.
Open door?
Okay, okay.
There's puzzles like...
Interesting.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Can I fall off?
You know what?
Maybe I shouldn't try.
But why would they give me the option to fall off if I couldn't fall, you know?
The mint never falls off.
I don't think I can.
No, I don't think I can.
That's good to know then.
This one's really long.
They even have paintings down here.
This one is really romantic.
With the sexy cages.
The mood lighting.
Oh, and the goop.
The most romantic of it all.
Probably.
Let's go straight.
More goop?
This is where my lovely slime girlfriend lives.
You know?
Aw, he's still chillin' there.
He's like in the same spot.
Aww.
How does the goop taste?
Probably like a line.
What is that?
Hal?
Anyway...
Oh!
First up... oh!
Mary, finally!
Third is Bram.
And he is stoked to be here.
Mrs. Spook!
Everyone's been waiting for Mito!
I feel like Goop would love Gwyneth Paltrow.
Who's that?
What's this one?
Mall of the Spook!
Spooky car!
Oh, it's out of order.
Which one do you guys want to play?
No?
No to the games?
Oh.
I'm already playing.
Meow!
No one's gonna slow me down, baby!
There's no jump scares in this game, are there?
Wow!
Drift!
Why are the cars not on the road?
Why are the cars...
Oh gosh, I feel like I'm gonna play...
You know that commercial of the car?
And then... Oh!
I just killed a person, I think.
Oh!
I just...
Sorry.
Um... Oh, I have to kill them!
Oh!
Oh, oops.
I thought I was just driving.
Oh, I took out a tree!
Vehicular manslaughter!
Oh yeah!
Wait!
Oh, they're still spinning.
Four!
Five!
There they go.
Hey!
You're not allowed to be here.
There we go!
Oh!
We'll come back to him.
I think.
Oh my gosh, I gotta kill them all first.
Meow!
But you know that commercial of the car?
Like driving and then it has the pop-up zombie and it like...
Got everybody as a kid.
Oh, I've hit that tree before once.
Hey, where did all these cars come from?
Hahaha!
Yeah!
The ancient jump scare.
I know!
That's what...
I feel like...
Is gonna happen here.
Wait, this is only stage one.
I wasted so much time thinking that I was just supposed to drive around.
Oh, here's a guy.
Oh!
I wasn't looking at the road!
I took out two trees!
Where's the rest of the cars?
Hello?
Yeah, deforestation, everybody.
Oh!
There's a guy.
Two guys!
You killed them all.
No, there's three left!
This is so fun.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, one guy, one guy, one guy.
Get one guy, get one guy, get one guy, get one guy.
Get one guy, get one guy, get one guy.
Crying doesn't pay?
Is that what she says?
Hahaha!
Is there a special for taking out the trees too?
No really, where is he?
I'll take out the trees while I'm waiting.
Get the one guy.
I'm looking for him!
He's a trickster!
Where is he?
Can you imagine if you missed?
That would be so... Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, how do I get out?
There we go.
That was good fun!
Wait, I kind of want to play all of them now.
Oh!
Oh my god!
This is...
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, okay.
I do have to press.
Oh, ow!
What's the point of this one?
Oh!
Kind of a bot though.
I should just have my auto...
Oh my god!
The flashing is kind of killing me though.
Why is it flashing so much?
Oh!
It's flashing a lot!
I don't like this one though.
This one flashes too much.
Who am I?
Am I spooky?
What am I?
Am I collecting these?
Or...
What am I doing?
I'm not even eating them.
Nothing's happening.
Oh, there he is!
He's eating them!
Ah!
Spooky Inception.
Metagamer.
I don't know.
Introducing some ghosts!
First up is Minta!
Yeah!
Like an inverse Pac-Man.
Yeah, I was...
Oops, my bad.
There we go.
Yeah, I was spooky.
That was a fun little break.
Yeah!
Back into the spooky mansion!
Oh!
Whoa!
What the hell is this?
Oh my god!
Raptor head!
Meat man.
Uh oh.
That's not good.
I think this means something bad.
What's here?
Subject 5 is growing more and more restless.
I told Spook we need more funds for sedatives.
But she just laughed and flew into the ceiling!
Without more chemicals to keep these things down.
So I'm not sure how much more...
How much longer we can keep them here safely.
Generic lab assistant.
I got the key card.
Where does that take me though?
Uh oh.
Something's really loud.
It sounds like something's right behind this door.
What is that?
Uh oh.
He's gonna come out of the ceiling.
I believe Subject 5 is loose!
The glass around its container is shattered.
I can faintly hear clicking coming from the ceiling.
I don't know what will happen now.
If it is out and alive, then it is probably my last resort.
The clicking is getting louder now.
Oh no!
Generic lab...
Ah!
Oh shoot.
How did I live?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
Oh my god.
It's not... I kind of hear the clicking.
Ouch!
Ouchy, ouchy, ouchy.
Oh god, oh god, he's gonna kill me.
Oh god, he's gonna kill me real.
Oh god, I'm trying to run.
I'm trying to sprint.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is messed up.
Get out of my eyes!
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, he's gonna come out from the ceiling.
Yep!
Oh god, I'm just gonna run to the end.
Ah!
I scream!
We all scream!
Four!
Oh shoot.
I wasn't gaming.
I should have...
I should have known.
Is it the same layout as before?
If it is...
Yes, it is!
Hallelujah!
Okay.
Oh, I think I'm safer now.
The music stopped.
Eric, thanks for the...
Oh, he's screaming.
I want some cookies and cream right now.
He's generated even.
How kind.
Me!
Free!
I scream!
Oh, you're the brains behind this operation, eh?
Hmm.
Very cool.
Which way did I come from?
135?
Oh, green.
Goop room.
Ah.
Subject 5 is probably the main specimen that scares me way more than the goop.
Is there some...
Wait.
Should I be scared of the goop?
Should I be...
Oh, I think my cat went out in a second.
Hold on.
Should I be afraid of the goop?
Ah!
I like the decor.
How you doing, pies?
She's just walking around.
Hold on.
Are you okay?
Yeah, let me let her out of my room.
One second.
Come here, girly girl.
You stinky girl.
When she gets too excited, she farts.
She stinks up the place.
Oh, let me let her out.
One second.
Hmm.
One of my cats does the same.
Yeah, cats are so funny.
Hello, Chatomito.
Hello!
I'm telling you.
This is like...
the most romantic.
Oh.
It's just like...
It's trying to get closer to me even.
Oh.
I think the goop is flirting with me.
Donk?
What does donk mean?
Oh, ding!
Okay, so...
Huh?
Ding?
Donk?
Right?
Left?
Straight?
Right?
Left?
Straight?
Right?
Left?
Okay, right?
Yippee!
Don't go to the light.
Gosh, that was like really familiar.
You did it.
Yay!
Where's the windfisher?
Boop, boop, boop!
Boop, boop!
Shit!
Wait, there's no music now.
To tell me if I'm getting chased or not.
Yippee!
150.
You're being chased.
Keep that blood pumping.
Axe, chop till you drop.
Hmm.
Here we go.
Love the view.
There's 850 more rooms!
Wooo!
From a week-long trip.
Week -long!
Wowee.
Hope you had fun.
I wonder what the theme is going to be this time.
We had specimens.
I'm done with jail.
Give me goop.
Can't help but imagine someone making sugar cookies.
Oh my gosh.
Minto.
If I could collaborate with a bakery, they make minto cookies.
That would be so fun.
Okay, we're getting more goop now.
I'm getting more goop now.
That's what I'm talking about.
Okay, we're getting way more goop.
Oh shoot.
Oh gosh.
I heard him.
No!
Oh!
We're in a school!
Oh gosh.
How do I know if I'm getting chased?
Locked.
This one's kind of spooky.
Actually.
I don't like it.
It's just a flashlight.
Wait, I'm scared!
Ah!
Oh, there's classrooms.
Why is this in Japanese?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can't read.
What?
Huh?
I don't think it...
That's it.
I can't read the first two.
I can read them like...
Two... something.
Maybe?
I can't remember.
I think it's gibberish.
Because it doesn't...
Oh, let's keep going.
I'm hearing things.
Locked.
Is this where I came from?
Oh, there's a note.
I can't read it.
Matsuri!
Never came to class today.
I hope she made it home okay.
Matsuri of Hololive fame!
Hatsune Miku!
Uh oh.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Am I going the right way?
Where's the person?
Oh, this is the first one.
Wait.
I think I'm lost.
Wait, maybe I went down this...
Maybe I'm supposed to go this way.
Oh, there it is.
We're heading... we're continuing forward, everybody.
Not to worry.
What's that sound?
That's a light.
Locked.
Okay.
Three months keeping me alive through my thesis.
Oh my god, Esper!
You got this!
You got this.
Oh my gosh!
It's Doom!
Oh, what's that sound?
What's chasing me?
I don't even know what's chasing me.
Why has it got to be a skelly man that spooks me, man?
What's chasing me?
It sounds lovely though!
That's me!
Oh my god, it's getting really loud.
Oh shit, it's getting really... I think we're okay.
I mean, we're not okay, but you know what I mean.
Leave me alone!
Just wants a hug.
Is she gonna chase me forever?
Until 200?
I
think we made it!
Now there's just another ambiance that's freaking me out.
You sure?
Just run.
Yeah!
Oh no, 10 more!
10 more!
Until... safe... room... right?
It's every...
I'm going, I'm going.
She just went to Membu ship.
Hello?
Yes, hello?
Hi!
Ah!
Hello?
Oh!
Wait!
They were responding finally!
No!
Oh shoot!
No...no...no!
Who are you talking to?
We made it!
Hang in...wait, where's our other poster?
Should be a heart rate monitor for this?
Oh my gosh...no!
Monsters and ghosts are just misunderstood.
They want to be friends.
Yeah!
I
wonder what ever happened to that guy that drank the wine.
Whoa!
It's going pretty fast.
So cute.
Wow!
SCP decor!
Uh oh.
Oh no, not this again.
No, not this room again.
No.
Oh wait.
Oh, oh, I missed it already.
Not this one again.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, here's a note!
This is such a surprise that there...oh!
Oh wait, it's the same note as before.
Oh, but it didn't work.
Okay.
Do I go back?
Maybe I read it and then go to the next one?
What the?
Ah!
Yippee!
Who's sitting in the time-out chair?
Little dummy.
I wonder if this will ever be in order.
Shame corner.
Shame, shame, shame.
Oh no, all the posters.
La, la, la, la.
Oh.
Hey, this all looks so familiar.
This all looks so familiar.
Hmm.
The despair chair.
You can't fall down?
Yeah, you can't fall.
Which is pretty nice, actually.
Guess you can only die...
What the?
What was that?
Oh.
I didn't even see it.
Gamers don't look up.
Oh.
Ah!
Yeah, we've been here before too.
Hmm.
We went to the left on...
Silent Hill?
Oh no.
Maybe I should have gone to the left again.
I don't like this.
Oh my god!
The darkness is slowly consuming us now.
I don't think our rituals will appease it much longer.
How are we supposed to know this would happen?
This is so...
Feels so Silent Hill 3.
It's not really our fault.
We just did what Mother has told us to do in this sort of situation.
Oh.
Broken.
Mother is not pleased with us, but how were we supposed to know that the girl wasn't pure?
What was that?
Oh.
Breathe.
Weird.
We're getting all the lore here.
Oh my goodness.
What did you do to be behind here?
Um.
Wait.
Which way?
This way, right?
Broken.
We're getting all the lore in here.
Oh.
Not in there.
Broke.
We're getting all the lore in here.
Oh.
This one again.
I think.
Let's just go straight.
My vision.
Looks like a QR code.
Oh my god.
I know I'm going slow.
I'm just...
Oh.
Okay.
I think I need to go fast now.
I think I need to go fast.
Oh my god.
Woah.
This is really trippy.
Oh my god.
My brain.
Woah.
I don't feel like I'm moving at all.
Oh my god.
No.
Why was he right there?
I'm just gonna go to the end.
Oh my goodness.
We made it.
Are you safe?
I think so.
We'll be safer.
No!
Oh, wait.
Oh shit, never mind.
Just kidding!
This is fucked up.
Where's my safe room?
Oh wait, it's every 50, isn't it?
I'm an idiot!
No!
I missed your mother!
I can't even get scared by you!
Oh my goodness.
No, not the goop right in front of the door!
I can't even appreciate the rooms.
I just gotta run from goop, guys.
Okay.
Alright, these are all the same.
Oh gosh.
More goop.
Confusion over fear.
That was unfair!
Oh wait!
I thought I was safe finally!
You're never safe in the spooky mansion!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Run, run, run.
Oh, there's a chair up there for some reason.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao.
We're almost there, we're almost there!
For reals this time!
For real this time!
I did!
Okay.
You know, I can sound like spooky too.
You're doing so great.
Thank you for, um, for playing the game.
Password pumpkin!
Thanks for playing the game, you're doing so well.
What's the password for, actually?
What's this too?
Thanks for the present.
Spooky.
Password pumpkin.
Sike!
I'm starting to think she doesn't like me.
Is it because I'm also a ghost?
Do you think she feels a little bit of...
Um...
A little bit of competition?
Perhaps?
Meh-hups?
Little ghost rivalry?
Now she's threatened by me?
She knows.
Thanks for making a video about the Akiba maid work.
A pop-up.
I was able to go because you let me know it existed.
Yeah, of course!
Thanks for watching it!
Bye!
This room stresses me out, so much.
Cause it's so long, you know?
Spitter.
Little spitter guy...
At least it's...
I was gonna say, at least it's always the same, but it just changed!
What?
Good to know.
It changed.
Wait, but there's no note there.
Oh, this again.
Alright.
Front!
Oh, bong bong.
Right.
Straight.
Straight, right.
Right.
Okay, straight.
Left.
Straight, right, left.
Straight, right, left, left!
Uh oh.
Oh, it's the cat dogs again!
What if I press it?
It's pretty intimidating.
Access specimen database.
Docile.
Total fatalities 4!
Method heart attack.
A cardboard cut out figure that springs out from the walls.
Proved not very effective against healthy subjects.
That guy sucks.
Hold on, I'm turning the music down.
It's too ringy in my ears.
Oh!
This guy!
Active.
Total fatalities 137.
Method physical tearing.
A mostly semi-solid based specter that frequently changes matter states.
Proved very effective against weaker or slower subjects.
What is this one?
Infectious bite.
Test specimen.
Oh, being developed!
This is the spider!
Should prove useful when released.
Trials have shown it adequately effective to average subjects.
Oh!
We've seen her.
14th century spirit that was contained and relocated here.
Tests have yet to reveal origins but all relevant information has been placed into testing chamber.
Proved effective not greatly more than previous specimens.
We've seen this guy too, right?
He's the one that made the room all crazy.
I can fix her.
A creature found inside the church of a small town.
Subjects are lost after contact...
with the specimen.
What did that say?
What?
Oh!
Method!
Commethed?
Commethed of...
Why is it written like that?
That's bad.
The killing is unknown.
Proved extremely effective against subjects with mental issues or weak wills.
Oh!
A wooden sized life puppet.
Oh, it's also active.
Found floating in a reservoir where a town has once been.
Specimen is active despite appearance and has proved very effective on subjects who disregard it or have vision impairments.
Okay...
What do I do with him?
He looks like...
Oh my gosh, he looks like Ben Drowned.
Wait, someone also said Ben Drowned!
He looks just like the Mask Seller.
Oh, error.
Dang it.
Interesting.
So we have one more guy we need to...
What is that?
Oh shoot.
What the hell was that?
I think I'm getting chased after.
Oh, this guy again.
Oh god.
I've already dealt with you!
Please!
I think I go to the right now, right?
Please be right.
Please be correct.
No!
I'm gonna die.
At least he's slow.
Oh my god, he hits a lot of damage though.
Oh my gosh.
Please!
I can't tell which way is right.
Yes, okay.
There's a candle there.
Okay.
We made it.
My head hurts.
How do you think I feel?
Not in the green room!
Goop attack!
Is he gone?
I think he's gone.
We haven't gotten any notes or anything recently.
Hey, I'm Buddy Joe and I'm lost.
Oh, you guys can't see the room number?
Let me move you down then.
Sorry, I didn't realize you couldn't see the room number.
Oh wait, hold on.
One more second.
Now you can.
Okay.
I never go this way.
Oh, it's just a loop.
The other way is faster.
Okay.
Oh!
Hello?
I don't know if you want to look directly into the fan.
Um, yes, hello?
Hello?
I was counting the whole time.
Hi!
Hello?
Yes, hi.
Hi.
Hello?
I don't know if you want to look directly into the fan.
Um, yes, hello?
Hello?
Uh oh.
This music sounds different.
Oh, read.
I think this is my last note.
I'm going to die having never found my escape.
But that's really not...
But that's really...
But really that's not true.
This place was like my escape.
My escape from everything else.
In the end, my death is kind of romantic.
Our romance sky!
This place is finally starting to affect me.
I've seen enough horror movies to know how to survive a simple ghost or two.
But these monsters keep getting faster and stranger.
Is that a different man?
Unless we're just seeing some of his notes now.
This death is so romantic.
To be or not to be.
Uh oh.
I'm getting...
Yep.
No!
Not you guys!
Leave me alone!
Goopy ghost.
Would you guys prefer if I was more goopy or...
How do you like your ghosts?
Moist?
Am I going the right way?
Please say yes.
More wispy.
You're fine the way you are?
You're so sweet!
You accept me as I am?
Yippee!
I wish I could crouch.
Wait, what's it say?
In order to survive this house, I need to keep writing notes.
Must do everything a central protagonist would and hope this is one of those stories.
Insert obscure horror reference that no one gets and misinterprets as instruction somehow.
Is this him?
No.
This is great for me though.
I think I'm in love with him.
I think I'm in love with him!
And now he's a ghost!
We can be together!
This is our true romance.
I want your lovin' I want your romance You and me, we'll write a good romance
Caught in a spooky mansion
Caught in a spooky mansion Spooky mansion Green Pink
Petavie He's gonna get me!
He's gonna get me!
Attack me!
He's gonna get me.
He's gonna get me!
I was not afraid.
Hi.
Of course we accept you as you are.
The coolest, prettiest, cutest ghost?
Oh wait, Polly from Mon...
The only Polly I know is Polly Pocket.
Let's try again.
Maybe if I read it enough.
Maybe it knows that I'm not reading it.
Shame.
What's this music?
Or rather, ambience.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
Read, Minto, read.
I've read it before!
That's a mute.
Why is it...
Uh oh.
Woah.
Woah!
Oh.
Oh!
This one.
Cool!
Oh, it's locked.
Um...
Can I just run through?
Try this one.
Oh...
Wow!
I can't... wait.
Okay, there we go.
One day a strange merchant came to town.
He sold handmade puppets and trinkets to all the children...
and all the children loved his store and his gifts.
But the town couldn't support his store because of...
the other shops were failing.
The other shopkeepers became jealous.
So one night, some of the townspeople took all his puppets...
and threw them into the river!
Uh oh.
Uh oh, we're on the puppet guy.
Pick up the key.
But just afterwards...
he came running to the river crying and wailing...
that his children were being drow...
bed drowned.
He dove into the river...
trying to save his possessions.
The townspeople, bitter and still angry...
watched him frantically thrash and dive into the river...
until he never came back...
to the surface...
of the water.
Ben drowned real!
What do I do with this...
with the puppet though?
It said like I should...
pay attention to him or something?
Oh.
Hold on, let's read first.
Hold on, maybe it's this one.
Oh.
Although not what they wanted...
the shopkeepers were satisfied.
Years later...
the children of the town began to go missing.
And as more and more children disappeared...
people began to find more and more puppets in the forest...
and around the river.
These puppets seemed almost to look like...
the missing children sometimes.
What do you say mint for?
What happened?
I don't know.
Swimming lessons get good, Ben.
I'm quite spooked by this.
He has a key.
I think.
Nope, he has a thing to kill me.
Oh, he looks really sad.
Ouch!
I'm sorry.
Wait,
what just happened?
Oh.
Yes, sir.
Oh, shoot.
No, sir.
There he is.
Just keep on going.
Oh, I can open with my back.
Oh my gosh.
Open.
Nice.
Hello.
Okay.
This is fine.
Open.
How am I opening them?
I don't know.
Oh, gosh.
With the goop?
Oh, this is kind of evil, isn't it?
Yes, sir.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
No way.
He looks...
Oh god.
Okay.
We've gone through this room so many times.
Once I can't see him anymore, I have to find out where he goes.
Okay.
We got this.
I'm doing my best.
I'm like, I've done this room so many times.
I'm going to know where he's at.
Or I'm going to know how to get there.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe this way.
Okay.
It was the other...
Ouch!
I was looking at you, you little bitch.
Don't even...
Don't even act like that to me.
I was giving you all the attention that you...
desired.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
We're fine.
Ouch!
We made it!
Oh my god.
Which one's that?
You walk into him?
No, I think you can walk into him, right?
It's just...
Yeah, he's persistent, isn't he?
Oh!
Oh my god!
We did it!
Oh, he'll hurt you if you walk into him?
Oh, okay.
I'm just kidding.
Sometimes there's that...
really loud ambiance.
Hear it?
It's a big old rumbling in my ear.
What is that sound?
Oh, no, please.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I knew it!
I was like, wait, I'm slow.
Why am I slow?
Oh, come on.
These guys cheat!
Oh, you are cheating for real.
Please be right.
Yes.
I hear you.
Not the goop ghost!
No!
Oh, gosh.
I'm just gonna guess.
I think I'm right.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Too much goop!
There never has to be a goopy ghost!
Nice.
There's no clipping.
Oh, gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Still more.
Not the ectoplasm.
This is a severe case of ectoplasm.
I'll tell you that.
I would never all over the floor.
Maybe once.
I think we're good.
Nice!
I think we're okay.
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
What are these sounds?
Oh.
This room again.
We went to the right last time.
Let's go to the left.
The right was really scary.
And I didn't like it.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Is this it?
Wait.
Where's my checkpoint?
I'm at 350.
Wait.
My checkpoint.
No way.
God.
Oh my god.
Once they start introducing this guy with other characters, it's going to be...
It's so jover.
Just run.
I'm surprised I lived through that.
Not going to lie.
Oh gosh.
No stamina.
He's probably the trickiest in the game.
He is tricky.
Ta-da.
Open him up my cheeks.
I feel like I don't even have a chance to retry anymore.
I'm fighting for my afterlife here.
Hey.
You?
Yeah, you?
Hey Mint, look here.
I see you.
Okay.
What are you hiding behind your back there, buddy?
He looks really sheepish.
He's like, oh gosh.
I just want to be friends with you.
I wouldn't hurt you ever.
You're my bestie.
Look at that.
He's shy.
Um, yeah.
Me too.
I actually don't know if I can fall into the goo.
I would really not like to find out.
Where are you?
Did he give up?
Oh, it's this room again.
Alrighty.
Let's go right.
Bing bong.
Left.
Straight.
Right.
Left.
Straight.
Oh.
Yippee.
Bong bong.
I like the pink rooms.
Back rooms, yellow rooms, pink rooms.
Green rooms.
Mint gaming.
Haha.
Yeah.
Hehehe.
Orange rooms?
No.
Nah, I love orange.
My Oshis color is orange.
Actually, I feel like I have an Oshi that is every color at this point.
My Oshis are the dang rainbow at this point.
Quite the long room.
A true DD.
I know.
But usually...
I pick...
Usually my favorite members are blue.
Your Oshi is Garfield and yours isn't?
Woah.
Oh no.
Am I being chased through here?
Please say no.
Is Sonic your Oshi?
Hmm.
When I was a kid I used to like Tails.
The most.
Oh gosh.
So...
The Smurfs?
I love...
blue people.
Base Tails enjoyer.
I always thought he was so cute.
There's different kinds of ghosts.
I wonder what kind you are, Mint.
Revenant?
Poltergeist?
Wraith perhaps?
I'm a Yurei.
I'm a vengeful ghost.
Uh oh.
What's that sound?
What is this?
What's chasing after me?
Is this the girl?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's this...
room again.
But we already did this, right?
Is there anything new?
Specimen 7.
Did I even miss this before?
Specimen is constantly changing form and attributes depending on subject's personality but most common form resembles a wall of moving anatomy symbols.
Only effective on subjects with past trauma or a history of psychological issues.
Me?
Outer Wilds!
Absorption?
A floating figure that appeared in a test chamber a few years after it was filled with what was believed to be...
to just be unusually violent deer.
Specimen seems to engulf subjects and absorb them into its torso region.
Proved extremely effective on violent subjects.
Deer.
Deer, deer, deer, deer, deer, deer...
Dang it.
It'll let me modify it eventually, right?
Oh, there we go...
games.
Deer, deer, deer, deer...
Nooooooo!
Deer, deer, deer, deer, deer, deer!
Oh no!
No no no no no no no no no no!
Just three more, three more maybe?
Hopefully?
Oh yeah!
Oh!
Four hundred!
Yippee!
You can do it!
We can help Papa John's!
Oh gosh.
Checkpoints.
So now the checkpoints are after 100?
I feel like they should have changed that after 500.
Papa John's is making me want pizza.
Okay you guys, I gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
I gotta go use the little ghostie's room.
Is that okay?
I do have some ectoplasm that must...
You know what?
I'm gonna quit while I'm ahead.
I'll be right back!
Don't go anywhere.
I'm back!
Thanks for all the superchats!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
I swallowed my spit wrong.
Anyway...
Let's go down!
Did you wash your hands?
Of course I did!
Now I'm taking a sippy of my tea.
Oh my gosh, we're almost halfway there.
How long does it usually take to beat this game?
I feel like...
Did you save?
I did, right?
I did save, right?
We're just in a big ol' dungeon.
I'm gonna go down this way.
Maybe I...
Won't go down that way.
Um...
About three hours?
Oh, why?
Toast!
What's the DLC like?
Is it the same thing, but a hospital?
What was that sound?
Whoa!
What is this?
Threshold of consciousness.
It was more exploratory.
Here I go!
Oh!
Little cat!
Cute!
Oh, talk!
Well, hello there.
Are you lost, little one?
This place can help those who are ready, but expect turmoil more than you are used to.
Oh!
What's that mean?
Bye-bye, Kyubey.
Oh!
Oh, there's the door.
Yep.
Where the heck am I?
Oh!
Okay!
What that mean?
Is this therapy?
Oh my gosh, you guys!
I have a hand cam...
On...
Wednesday?
Oh...
But my nails...
My nail... My... Another nail of mine just broke!
Oh, do I want to touch... I don't want that to touch me, all right?
Two sides of the same coin.
Don't be ashamed.
Oh!
What does that... What does that mean?
Wow!
Oh, it's pointing at me!
My nails... My nails are not very nice.
I think I... You know... I'm a ghost.
It's like usually I wear gloves anyway, so you can see me better, so I'm not transparent, but...
I might just have to... I'm worried about building it with gloves on.
So basically I'm building like this...
Bookshelf...
Um...
Thing...
And it's... It's like... It looks like...
Oh...
Wasn't I just here?
Diorama... Yeah!
Put on your mask... Oh!
Follow the group.
Be who you are... Be... Come more than you...
Oh, God!
It's an office!
Oh, my God!
The mask you wear serves its purpose well.
But be careful not to lose yourself.
But my nails have been breaking so much this week.
I don't know why.
If you would like to name a kitten...
A little black cat...
Mint!
Hmm...
Salem?
Liquid?
A note.
Well, I still haven't died, so it appears I might be the protagonist.
But I'm not entirely sure.
I hope I'm not some side character that leaves notes for pointless exposition.
Also, I found a strange computer that gives the descriptions of the monsters.
And it seems like they're all called effective based on how many people they kill.
Yeah, I read that too.
This guy is me!
Shalashaska!
Shalashaska is a great name.
Oh!
Wait, there wasn't blood here on the brain before, was there?
Uh-oh.
I think Shalashaska is a great name for a cat.
Let's go to the left.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Oh.
These places are like safe zones, kinda.
Oh!
I'm seeing everything, little cat.
I've seen everything.
That doesn't look good.
Maybe I shouldn't keep talking to this guy.
Knowing your shadow can greatly help you.
But be ready to see what you'd rather not be.
Oh!
Whoa!
Uh-oh.
I don't wanna know!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't wanna know.
Whoa!
I like the music here, though.
Oh my gosh.
Was that a funky man?
Oh shit!
I don't know what's going on!
My mind is broken!
Oh, shoot.
I can't tell what's going on.
I'm just running.
Can't tell.
Just run?
Oh, I am!
Oh god.
Please be correct.
Okay.
I like the BGM.
It's kinda funky.
I like it.
I don't know if the guy on the wall is evil or what, but I'm not sticking around to find out.
This guy is spread eagle over here.
Like, come on!
Oh!
Hello, hello!
Hello!
All right.
Oh, it's this place again.
Um, right!
Oh.
Ah, left.
Straight.
That's all the Shasko it is.
She meows to it.
Left.
Straight.
Straight, right, straight, right, straight, right, left, straight, right, right, straight, right, right, left, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
right, right, right, right, right Left.
Oh my god!
It's the guy with the banana!
He's back.
I hope they're cute.
Summarize the cat.
Putting on personas is useful, but don't get too absorbed...
Wait, what?
Huh?
Oh my gosh, what's this?
It's getting so loud.
Whatever this ambiance is.
I'm just gonna keep running.
I hope the antagonist is cute too.
Woah, this is such a cool effect!
It looks like the candle was blown out and there's the smoke from it.
Doctor Squeals!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much!
Oh my god!
I didn't expect a toast there!
Oh, the in-game cat.
Why are we talking about multiple cats?
Get me out of here.
Hello, Fintmentum.
That's not my name.
Welcome to membership.
This is awesome.
Oh, sh**!
Thank you!
No!
I wish I could jump.
Jump out!
This guy sucks!
Thanks for the super chat!
Orpheee!
Where are you going to sleep?
Good night!
What is this?
I'm running!
Oh my god.
I thought I might be safe.
Nope, I'm running slowly.
Oh my goodness.
Two in a row!
This is messed up.
MESSED UP MESSED UP MESSED UP MESSED UP!
Oh my god, I went the wrong way.
Shoot!
Shoot shoot shoot shoot!
Shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot!
Oh gosh.
Welcome back, Marukami!
Back!
Locked?
I got jumpscared and it was locked.
I think the guy's not chasing after me anymore though.
Whoa, this is a very narrow hallway.
Specimens?
What is this?
Oh, cool!
Maybe I should've explored it.
AHHHH!
Oh my god, I forgot what it was.
Oh god, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Oh no no no no no no no.
Please please please please.
Not like this, not like this, not like this, not like this, not like this, not like this, not like this!
Ah.
She's cheating.
I mean if I was a ghost I would die... I mean I am a ghost, but...
If I could, I wooooood!
Miss Specimen, I'm on your siiiiide!
Please!
Aren't you already dead?
It's not fair, games never recognize my deadness.
They always assume that the person playing is alive!
They always assume!
And you know what assuming does?
If I could, I would!
It's true!
Yeah, assuming turns you into an ass.
You become a butt.
Let's go to the right.
Like a donkey.
Oh, this one's new.
Actually, it doesn't even give me the option to go to the other side.
Oh no, this is the long one!
Just kidding.
Thanks for the page.
I see that as a win- Ass a win-win.
Donkey.
Doesn't that mean I get a Dragon GF?
Put some respect on that title.
It's a dragon wife!
He has kids with her!
Donkey has children with the dragon!
Good for him.
Shrek 5 hype.
Oh yeah, let's go check this out now.
Oh, why did I check it out?
Why did I check it out?
I made it!
You just keep on going, don't you?
Well, the next door has been fixed up for you.
So enjoy, and keep moving on.
You little...
Fleshy, I want.
That's not me at all!
I mean, I'm not fleshy.
I don't know the last time I've had flesh.
Spooky.
We're halfway there!
Cheese!
First pumpkin, then cheese.
Dang.
Are you sure it's out of order?
Wait, so we're not going down anymore?
I can't believe we're halfway there, you guys.
Oh, just kidding.
Uh-oh, now some doors are fake?
I just realized that I never had a mentor figure.
Trial or leaving home scene.
That means the story isn't following the archetypes to make me a traditional hero.
Which means I can be killed off.
Well, it was nice for at least...
Oh, a little while at least.
Room 51!
52!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Can I go back?
I can't!
She's...
She's cheating!
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no!
Turn off...
Oh, no.
Wait a second.
Oh, they can come through.
Even though the room is really skinny, they can still come through?
Oh, yep.
No way.
Cannot release twice.
Exit through express.
Express turn on!
Yippee!
Jeez game!
Right!
Straight!
Left!
Oh.
Right.
Straight.
Am I cheating?
What?
Straight.
Right.
Left.
Straight.
Right.
Oh,
come on.
Ugh.
These guys are such a pain in my side.
What's that music?
Uh-oh.
This is a new room.
Why do I hear like a music box?
Oh, gosh.
There's so much here!
Unfair.
The goopy!
These guys are everywhere.
I hear.
Well, that's a new one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Let's get out of here.
Skedaddleaddle.
This place needs a maid!
I would never keep my mansion looking so horrible.
You guys are so annoying.
Do you guys hear the music?
I can't tell if it's ambience or...
something.
What was that?
Purple!
Oh, this room is really purple.
Wowee.
Scream lagged the stream?
There's lag.
I wonder if maybe it's the YouTube side.
The Grimace Room?
Okay, last time...
I don't remember.
Let's go this way.
Oh, shoot.
Why does this keep happening to me?
Is he gonna get me?
Okay.
I'm reading the note.
No!
Must I get caught once?
Oh, this was such a surprise that there would be another entry.
Another actual entry.
Read it with feeling.
Oh, this was such a surprise.
Okay, let's just go get got.
You guys are gonna scream.
Ready?
Screeee...
Oh.
You guys are going to scream.
Screeeeam!
I actually don't mind that room though now because it's guaranteed basically to be safe.
It's just a guy that comes after me.
Suspiciously long hallway.
That got me.
Oh!
Oh, it's this guy.
Open.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Open, open.
Oh gosh, I hate these rooms with him.
They're really hard.
These ones are not so bad.
Wait, weren't we just down there below?
That's so funny.
Oh, now we're back down here below.
He's just so goofy.
Yeah, he doesn't really scare me.
Oh gosh.
He's just frustrating to deal with because he's one of those types of enemies.
Every horror game has this enemy.
Ooh, the music's getting freaky though.
He's very fast.
He is!
He is.
You have to be really on your toes with this guy.
Whoa!
Whoa.
Oh, I'm in...
I'm a peasant man.
Whoa, what is this?
For a while, I thought I had really escaped this place.
But despite the trees and flora, I think this is actually just another room I did.
Oh, I room.
Oh, I did, however, find deer!
So I might at least get to eat.
They make some strange sounds though.
What did they say about these guys?
Do I just have to run from them?
Oh gosh.
Run from the deer?
The violent deer?
I left the deer behind.
Can I take that?
Extra dimensionally choppy.
What do I do?
Oh, I chopped down the door.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Ow!
Whoa.
Freaky.
Oh, another place with like rooms and stuff.
Okay.
Any lore?
This one?
Locked.
Oh, I got a key.
I didn't even notice it before.
Unless it wasn't there before.
I don't know.
This next specimen is dangerous.
Yeah, I don't like him.
Oh god.
Okay.
Yes, deer!
No, deer!
What are you saying?
I'm cutting you off.
You're too slow.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Out of my way, please.
Oh god.
Join us.
Cutting you off, man.
I'm not listening.
I don't want anything to do with your weird cult, okay?
My what?
What'd you say?
You have to speak up!
There should be a mod that like replaces what they say with that song.
Anyway.
The deer club.
Oh, he wants to give hugs.
I think of, um...
The deer that are in Nara that like get aggressive with you when you try to feed them.
Shika no ko no ko no ko koshita anta.
Shika no ko no ko no ko koshita...
Do I still have my axe?
I do!
Very nice.
I was like...
Okay.
Alrighty.
I haven't started any new anime this season.
Um...
But it seems like there's a lot of really great stuff this season.
So...
I should get on it.
It's just been kind of too...
Too busy.
I think I won't be able to really watch too much until like probably...
I don't know.
I don't want to wait until the season's over but...
Cause then...
You know it's always harder to get motivated to watch something once it's over.
Like it's easier to watch it week by week.
Oh shoot.
I was like, am I slow or what?
No more goop!
Say it with me!
Oh my god.
No more goop!
Oh shoot.
I have to go this way.
Hit the goop?
I can't.
Unless I can...
Oh my gosh.
There's even more goop!
Non-stop goop!
I think the goop is tasty.
It really looks like it would taste like a green Gatorade or you know the yellow Gatorades.
Pick one.
I don't like this.
I feel like one is going to lead to room 600 and one isn't.
One is going to lead to a save point and one is not.
A tiger by the toe.
Whippy hollers let him go.
My mom said to pick the very best one and you are it.
Pillar.
Make like a tree and die.
Coming this fall.
Keep that blood pumping.
We're going down down and we're running around.
Sugar word don't going down screaming.
I'll be your number one with a mullet.
Mother God complex cock it and pull it.
Starting off very exciting.
Endless hallway.
Another endless hallway.
Mint out boy.
Good night Mint.
Good night.
Did you guys have a good weekend?
Did you guys have fun?
Oh I still have my axe even.
That's exciting.
I like miserable weekend next to awesome weekend.
Meh.
It ended so so.
Before you know it it'll be the weekend.
Again?
Oh.
Day two.
Food supply depleted.
Water supply at 30%.
Mental health deteriorating.
Leaving notes behind to help others and mark where I've been.
If you were hired to scare visitors in this mansion.
How would I do it?
You know what they say.
Just be yourself.
Oh.
I feel like I'm in a different game.
What do they use to lock the doors in here?
Spookies.
Haha.
Woah.
This whole place is somehow even worse than the new GL labs.
Although it seems to have been constructed with a much larger budget than the new lab.
Nothing works quite right.
I can see why it was abandoned so quickly.
I wonder if there really is anything here worth salvaging.
Beep boop.
Woah.
We have some light.
Oh.
Okay.
Dead space time.
Yeah.
Right.
GL labs.
Let me guess.
Like the power only works for a certain amount of time or something crazy.
Oh.
Oh no.
I knew it.
No.
Why did I have to call it?
Oh my god.
Huh.
I don't like this.
This is...
What is that?
How many rooms am I getting through here?
615?
Oh.
6...
Spooky just said that there were things we needed to salvage from this place.
I'm starting to worry that a loose specimen may be included in the list of things for us to retrieve.
The power just shut off again.
Is everything broken in here?
My room didn't...
My room number didn't change at all.
Or did it?
I don't think it did though.
Oh.
There's nothing.
I don't know what to do.
I can't think well.
I feel strange.
I'm hiding from that thing.
I feel like something is growing on my skin.
I can't seem to tear it off fast enough and I'm losing a lot of blood.
What is going on?
What is going on here?
Uh oh.
You have to keep it close.
Close.
It becomes something else when it gets too far away.
Something I can't outrun.
Keep it close?
Oh my god.
Ah!
What the hell is that?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Keep it close.
What the?
Oh!
That thing!
I don't know what to do.
AHH!
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die?
No!
Oh, it's on me.
We're gaining health.
I think I can't run.
I think I have to walk.
Keep it close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, baby.
Come here, baby girl.
Bro, hey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Okay, okay.
How did I live?
Oh my god.
Oh no, no!
I was walking!
You're just too slow!
We're walking.
I'm walking too fast apparently.
When it gets too far away, he turns into a bug monster.
Excuse me!
Come on!
Come on, come on, come on!
It reminds me of something from Stranger Things.
Yeah, I'm taking my pet alien for a walk.
Love that movie Teeth.
Oh, nice long hallway for us to travel down.
You and me, buddy.
Yep.
Oh, I love you.
Yeah.
Became like a little head guy.
It was first a giant head, then became a hugger.
Just like a cat.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Really?
Not the time toast.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't mind this one so much.
It just makes it hard for us to, you know, for us to speed through these rooms, but that's okay.
There's always time for toast.
It makes it a little hard for us to go through these rooms really quickly, but that's okay.
Friend-shaped.
You guys kept mentioning that all these ghosts or all these monsters and stuff just want to hug.
And this is the first time I've really felt invited, you know?
This is the first time I've ever felt invited.
The monster that was inspired by the movie The Thing, which also inspired the very known game Among Us.
Oh wait, this monster.
Oh, this monster was inspired by The Thing.
I can see it.
I love that movie.
Which I did know inspired Among Us.
Oh, we're here!
Nine?
No.
No?
To take the den?
What does that mean?
Oh, that's our deer.
Is this the guy?
Yeah!
245!
That was almost me.
Not gonna lie.
Where are we taking them?
I don't know.
This one has zero deaths.
Zero fatalities, I mean.
I'm afraid of no ghost.
Can I change the house layout now?
Cool.
Take the dead to take the dead to...
What's that sound?
Sounds kinda wet.
Like a...
Sounds like that.
It would be kind of embarrassing to be the first kill.
I know, right?
Oh gosh.
It's really rumbly.
Someone's hungry!
Not me though?
You sure?
Virgil?
Did you eat?
Long hallway.
Oh goodness.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
No!
Please!
Ben...
I wonder what the line of...
He's like...
He's pointing at me like...
When do I get my hands on you?
Ouch!
Oh gosh!
Ah!
Ben!
I'm sorry, man.
Let's start over.
We're cool.
We're chill.
Oh gosh.
That guy went the wrong way.
Good old Ben.
Really?
I don't know.
That's a bit of a...
I don't know if good is the right...
Oh my gosh.
We get a little bit of a theremin action.
Or something.
I wanna learn the theremin so bad.
If I did a theremin learning stream, would you guys listen?
Yeah?
We can make some spooky Halloween music or something.
Ben.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Oh my goodness.
Hell yes, theremin stream.
I can actually do it with my mouth.
Can you axe him?
Oh my god.
Ben drowned!
Yeah!
You can hit the puppet with the axe.
Yeah, take that.
Bozo.
Sorry if your name is Ben.
Oh he's gone.
Yippee!
Pheromone.
Stream.
Like, scents?
Green.
It ain't easy being green.
Okay.
Stop killing Bennett's son.
He needs to stop hurting me.
I'm so glad that this game eventually has health recover.
And like a pretty quick pace too.
It's very forgiving.
This room again.
Left!
Straight!
Right.
Left.
Oh shoot.
Wait, it was right?
Right.
Left.
And straight.
Right.
Left.
And left.
The silliest march walk ever.
Hopping on one foot at one point.
Doing splits.
Yeah, exactly.
I like how they're...
I'm so curious about the lore.
For this game.
I want more.
I want more lore.
Give me more notes.
Give me more floating skull heads.
DLC.
Is that the hospital one?
There's two DLC focused on a lore?
What a suspiciously long way.
Oh and the dollhouse.
The dollhouse.
Locked.
Okay.
Rude.
I can't believe they just have random doors that are locked like that.
Oh shit.
No, no, no.
This is the girl, isn't it?
No!
Ice cream!
Do... do...
Oh, it's the girl.
It's the girl.
No, no.
No, girl, run away.
Run away from the girl.
Run away from girl.
She's like, Don't you want a ghost girlfriend?
She's a desperate woman.
I... I mean...
I
don't know what I want anymore.
I'm... I'm not ready for combat.
Please.
Oh my god.
The music is so loud.
Feels like she's right behind me.
Feels like she's breathing down my neck.
Girls have good ears!
Minto running away from a girl?
That's a first.
She's just intimidated.
She's like, Lovely ghost girl.
Let's be besties.
And I'm like, Hey, girly.
I don't know you.
Oh my god.
No way.
She's so fast.
Oh my god.
Is it because she can go through walls?
I'm like letting my...
I'm like using every inch of my...
Oh my gosh.
Of my...
Stamina.
When I get it back, I use it.
She's gonna get ya.
No.
Oh, we made it.
Good job, guys.
We're at...
Oh my gosh.
We're at 669.
Nice.
Six...
Mr. Brain.
We meet again.
The pinky and the brain.
And Larry.
One is a genius.
The other's insane.
And there's Larry.
They're laboratory mice.
I don't know what the rest is.
Do you guys remember that episode?
There's an episode.
Of pinky and the brain.
Yeah, I didn't...
What had happened was...
The place...
I think Warner Brothers had the show or whatever.
And they were like, Hey, you should add another mouse.
They were like, No, it's pinky and the brain.
You don't need a third mouse.
And they're like, No, add a third mouse to your show.
They're like, okay.
And so...
Out of pure spite, they added the most annoying character.
And then had him ruin the iconic opening of the show.
So...
Oh no.
And so...
It's just...
It's like my favorite example of...
What's the word?
Compliance...
Malicious compliance.
And then...
Nobody liked Larry enough to keep him in.
Wow, thank you for the pink!
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
No!
Oh no, no, no, no.
Oh gosh, please, please, please.
At least there's only one of them, but...
Oh my god, no.
Please, please, please.
They were like, add a human and they put in...
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
I can't read right now.
I'm getting attacked.
On every angle.
Hold on.
Oh shoot.
There's two of them.
I love malicious compliance so much.
Me too.
I'm getting gooped.
You guys.
Okay.
This guy...
This is a disgusting...
I think this is why I'm a ghost maid.
Because ghosts like this exist.
What do you think the maid cafe looks like after days of ghostly patrons, right?
Awful.
These are the worst types of customers.
I think we're good now.
Yippee.
Okay.
Maybe just a few more?
I can't tell anymore.
I don't know when the game is going to troll me.
Oh, allow.
Are ghost girls a type of slime girl?
They might be a ghosty slime girl.
I don't...
Hmm.
You're making me question my existence.
You're making me question things.
But I only want them to goop if they're hot.
And I'm trying not to be judgmental, but this guy is just overdoing it, you know?
Yippee!
Axe!
300 left.
Ah!
Smash!
Boo!
Thanks for the five giftin'!
Uh-oh.
What is that sound?
I'm just gonna keep going.
Are ghost slimes extra goopy?
Not extra.
If they were extra goopy...
You might want to consult your physician.
You might want to go to the boo-spital.
Why is it...
Oh!
What the heck is this?
Taste the beef!
I'm in a...
I'm in a liminal space?
It's broken.
Nasty.
Read?
Oh!
Well, I broke my one rule today.
The management doesn't give out actual lunch breaks, so I can't go anywhere.
And they won't allow outside food here.
I mean, they actually screamed at the last customer who did that.
Anyway...
I had a burger.
It wasn't bad.
And I don't feel sick.
And I have something... something...
I'm scared.
Broken.
They won't let...
Oh, but everybody can go into the ladies' room.
I was anxious getting a job here at first, but it seems like things are getting better.
This chain is really expanding, which is a shock, because just last week I heard the company was going broke.
Every day, more and more people show up to eat here.
Something still sets me off about the place.
And it's food, though.
So I'm going to try to not eat anything from here.
Oh!
I'm reading them out of order.
Oopsie.
Locked.
Oh.
Today was a weird day.
Men don't need to use restrooms!
Average number of orders continues to rise, as it has been.
But I don't know about the number of people.
Today I saw someone use the drive-thru and order a lot of food for one person.
And then about ten minutes later, they were back!
They ordered the same exact meals, and then they left again.
Then another ten minutes, they were back again.
Maybe they're just delivering food for a party or a hotel.
But it worries me for some reason.
100% beef.
And so now they ate it.
We read that in the bathroom.
Fun rules!
100% beef.
I don't want to leave yet.
What's in here, though?
We could go in.
Put your shoes away.
Wait, should we go in?
No screams.
Look out for snakes.
No alcohol.
No diving.
No hiding.
We will find you.
Look out for snake!
Note on the floor?
Oh!
This is strange.
I had a dream last night about this restaurant.
I know I was here.
But I also felt like I was in another place at the same time.
Everything looked so wrong.
Nothing was the right size and I kept hearing these strange animal noises.
Almost like wailing.
I guess I feel guilty for eating that burger the other day.
Also today I saw that man again.
The one who kept ordering every ten minutes.
But...
Oh, oh.
This time he never even left the parking lot.
He just got his meal parked and then got back in line.
He must have done it at least eight times before he left.
I'm scared.
Should I go in?
I'm so scared.
I'm scared.
It was fat man.
Go in?
Guys, if I die in here though, I think that's pretty bad.
Oh.
I don't think I'm crawling.
Metal Gear Pro...
Uh...
Hmm...
Oh!
Key.
Maybe I had to come in here for the key to leave.
Oh!
I did it!
But I got the key!
This is messed up.
I got the key!
Um...
Is there another key?
Wrong door.
Is this the bathroom?
Oh no, that was broken.
Uh...
Oh, this room!
Oh...
I don't like this at all.
I don't like...
I don't like this at all!
Um...
See?
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna run.
I don't understand this guy.
Oh my god!
Wait!
Oh, I had to.
Die it.
Maybe?
Or...
Is this part of the game?
Oh no.
I don't have my axe anymore.
Did I die?
Is this...
Is this what happens when you die?
Oh...
Get beefed.
Oh!
Uh...
Hello?
Beef.
Oh!
It was an actual death!
Oh, that's...
Uh...
Oh, he hides doors!
Huh?
Ah!
Blalala...
If I continue...
Oh!
Honestly, impressive you made it that far without losing.
Haha!
From 700.
700 with no death system?
That's really good?
Really?
That's good, I guess.
Save more often?
What are you talking about?
You can only save at the checkpoint!
You can only save at the checkpoint.
Oh!
There's even more here now.
This guy.
Oh!
Floating red figure that was found inside a secret area below a large abyss.
And twelve.
What is this one?
Oh my gosh!
It's that one Stephen King book!
Rose... Rose... Rose Manchin... Rose... Rose... Rose Red!
Yes!
Rose Red.
The Arby's Demon.
The specimen sometimes chooses a host to possess and uses them to attack the species.
The subject, with various means depending on the host's characteristics.
Not much is known about the origin of the mansion, but signs occasionally show an earlier massacre or tragedy has taken place within the mansion.
Proved very effective, but varies itself too often to be a reliable method of extraction.
So that's what they call it.
Extraction, eh?
Boom!
Well, we're back here.
I can't even tell...
So the demon guy, the Arby's Demon, he hides doors?
The mansion is a Clock Tower reference.
You know, I never played Clock Tower either.
I'm such a fake horror fan.
Really?
Double in a row?
Arby's Demon does hide doors.
Okay.
So I could have... I could have made it out, maybe.
Dang it.
I think I went the wrong way.
Yep.
I'm just a horror enthusiast.
There... Oh yeah!
Sorry.
There's like... I'm kind of picky about what kind of...
What kind of horror I like, though.
Typically.
I'm not just like, you know, like, to me...
Oh!
Remember this place?
To me, like, you know, Resident Evil and stuff...
I don't ever really consider horror.
Maybe 7.
Oh.
I guess we have to come here, don't we?
Dang it.
Do I have to read the notes again?
Resident Evil's more action than horror.
Yeah, exactly!
I always thought that too.
Okay.
Silent Hill I liked.
Oh, broken.
I'm just reading them just in case...
Oh, there's the note.
I'm reading them just in case...
There we go.
I have to.
Any upcoming horror movies you're excited for?
Um...
I just watched Red Letter Media's review on...
Long Legs, I think it was.
Which seemed okay.
Oh, I just realized you can't sprint in here.
Okay.
Good to know.
Long Legs is good.
Just gonna go the same way I did before.
Where's the key?
Oh, there it is.
Ping-pong.
The Witch.
Oh, yeah.
That one...
I like that one actually.
I don't mind slow, like, atmospheric horror, you know?
Okay.
So, this guy...
He hides the doors.
He hides doors.
This is gonna be tricky.
I'm only at 710, though.
So, if I lose 10 levels, I guess it's not...
I guess it's not the end of the wor...
End of the world.
Oh, God.
I'm scared, though.
That's so unfair!
And he flies.
Oh, I just saw it disappear.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, my God.
Get out of my way.
This is now, not the time.
Oh, my God.
He's gonna fly straight towards me.
I have no stamina.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know which way to go.
I'm gonna risk it this way.
Please be right.
It was not right.
I'm so tense right now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Thank goodness.
He's only...
Oh, is there one here?
Yes.
I was gonna say he's only hidden one door.
But there he goes, hiding a second one!
Oh, no.
This is the really long room.
No, this is evil.
Oh, my God.
I thought he was done chasing me.
For a second.
This is really evil to put me in a room with this guy.
Come on.
In this room?
With this guy who can float?
Oh, can I attack him?
I wonder.
Hey, quit bugging me.
I'm so tense.
Oh, my God.
Don't just...
Don't just disappear the door.
Oh, my God.
While I was in the middle of...
Please.
Leave me alone!
I'm glad I'm seeing them before he...
Before he disappears the...
No!
I'm so tense.
Wait, am I actually free?
We did it!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to have carpal tunnel from this.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah!
Okay.
Hold on.
I really need to stretch my hand.
Oh, it wasn't my mouse that I was death gripping.
It was the...
It was the wasdom to move.
I was just like...
Trying to...
I was trying to run as fast as I could.
How are you doing, buddy?
Now you have the meat.
Arby's.
Oh.
Clinging on to that W.
I...
No.
I really was.
Oh.
Day three.
Hallucinations are manifesting at increasing intervals.
The cause is probably...
I missed day one, didn't I?
The cause is probably sleep deprivation or...
Or a gas that is being pumped into the rooms.
I have...
Not yet been injured.
So I don't think the cause is a brain injury...
Or a blood clot.
Oh.
Look at you show off.
Has Rich Evans's laugh ever scared your cat?
I don't think so.
Meats.
What?
Are you speaking from experience?
Oh.
We're back here again.
Game room.
Not the same chair this time though.
Yawn got me to run.
Yawn.
Run.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop yawn.
Oh.
The sun.
Nah.
744.
Hallucinations are manifesting at increasing intervals.
Oh.
Day four.
I'm starting to lose track of time.
The battery on my phone became very low.
So I delegated it to save...
Delegated to save it in the case I find an exit.
Three months.
Three.
Thanks for three months.
Uh oh.
No.
Oh.
It's this room.
Okay.
One.
We don't read it.
Don't care.
This guy is gonna come after us.
Now.
Are you guys ready to scream?
Woo!
Oh.
Wha?
Okay.
Collegian.
I hope I said your name right.
Thanks for joining.
Left.
Right.
Straight.
Then go left.
Go left.
Straight.
Straight again.
Oh.
Straight.
Left.
Right.
Strait.
Left.
Straight.
Unlimited stamina to race to the end.
The final stretch!
Password cake.
She actually gave me a gift!
Unlimited stamina!
Cake.
Thank you so much for the gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Does it like take away my health or something?
Wait...
Why is my stamina not working anymore?
Wait, I have unlimited stamina but I can't run!
Oh my god, no way!
I can't run!
She's so evil!
She made sure your stamina doesn't run out!
Oh my god...
Wait, is it like this the rest of the game?
No...
And with the goop monster, this is so evil.
No, no, no, no.
With the goop monster, please!
Please, please, please!
Oh my gosh.
This is so evil.
Oh my god, what is that noise?
What was that?
Forgot to turn the volume back down.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh, I got it back!
Wait.
When did it come back?
Stamina is yellow again.
She's so rude!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I really thought it would be like that for the rest of the game.
766.
I can't remember.
Why did I come here?
Was there ever a purpose?
I believe death is steadily approaching me now.
The hallucinations can hurt me.
I'm out of provisions and I'm suddenly having violent heart palpitations.
Not the palpitations.
Ruh-roh.
Get stumped.
769.
Not the palpitations.
Emperor palpitations.
Emperor...
Oh!
Avid reader!
These are their stories.
That was the achievement.
Day 7.
Super Mintette!
Mint Nendo.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
They're watching over me.
I have a guardian angel!
Wait, what's this one again?
Wait, what's this one?
Oh shoot, I don't remember.
Oh, okay.
I know.
I know!
Beef
demon!
Beef demon!
And we've got the meats!
We've got the meats!
Yeah, it's kind of...
kind of icky though that his description doesn't say that he can get rid of the doors.
You know what I mean?
But I guess if you...
I think I... I think I got really unlucky in that I didn't have a room where I could say that he would do that.
You know what I mean?
Oh, we made it!
I just kept running.
So I had no idea.
I just thought it was a dead end.
I thought it was supposed to happen that way.
I smell like beef.
788, baby.
That was unlucky.
Yeah, I think so too.
And then, you know, when I'm running away I don't really... I can't...
Oh my god!
Wait, what is this one?
Oh, it's this guy!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
It's this guy!
Okay, never mind.
We're good.
Come on, baby!
Come on, baby, baby!
The thing.
It's the thing.
Yeah.
The thing.
It's the thing.
Yeah.
I got it.
Come on, baby!
Yeah.
Oh!
This way.
Uh-oh.
Not this way!
Rude.
Rude, rude, rude, rude, rude.
Rude, rude, rude, rude, rude, rude.
Yep.
Oh my god.
No!
How did I get too far away from you, huh?
The rude sandstorm.
Oh!
We made it!
Oh my gosh!
800!
Yippee!
We're going down, down.
Bigger, bigger, bigger, down.
Sugar, we're going down.
Screaming!
Number one with the mullet.
A number one cockpit.
Cockpit and bullet.
Mint gaming.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Left.
800.
This is a new room.
Interesting.
Oh no!
No!
I'm trapped in the goop.
Trapped in the O's.
These goop guys...
are too...
nasty.
Woah!
Remilia-sama?
Is this Castlevania?
I like this.
This is new.
This mansion is strange.
I think the bricks and wood are actually just painted on.
Everything still feels kind of fake.
Also I keep hearing movement and voices below me.
Maybe other survivors are hiding down there.
Yeah.
Other survivors.
Oh look, there's the door.
But I want to explore.
Oh, broken.
A wine cellar?
Woah!
Frog!
Thank you for the Hakusuba!
Number one combo.
Fries and some nuggets.
I can hear him coming down the hallway.
I need to hide but I don't know where.
I now know this is not an exit or a resting place.
It's just another specimen room.
I think he's outside the door now.
Uh oh.
Hide?
No, no, no, no.
I'm hiding.
Can he see me?
Wait, will he actually be able to see me?
Oh my god.
Scary.
That's actually really scary.
Oh my gosh.
He can smell you take a bath, stinky.
Hey!
He can smell you guys!
He can smell!
I'm getting hit.
The heck?
Everything is
broken.
I don't want to die here.
Locked.
Upstairs maybe?
I can smell.
Everything is locked!
I somehow managed to get away.
But I don't know for how long.
I hear him even when I know he's not there.
It's like he isn't even real.
But instead of my own...
Instead of my own fears manifesting themselves and stalking me.
Can I hide in here?
Is there a key?
Uh...
I only watch you, Mint.
I...
No!
Watch whoever you want to watch.
Did I miss something?
Hmm...
Key in the fireplace?
Oh!
Bedroom key.
Thank you!
Oh...
Maybe upstairs is a bedroom.
Or down here.
I watch everyone except...
Mint.
Oh wait, this is where we came from.
Hide.
He can...
He knows how to smell.
I can smell.
So scary.
No way!
He can smell!
And he can see!
He has...
I think he has all five senses, you guys.
This is bad.
Oh wait, what's this over here?
The music is awesome.
What is this?
Wow, a mansion!
Inside another mansion.
Maybe I've made it all the way to the end of the house.
Maybe this is like a resting place or another entrance perhaps.
Whatever the case, I think this is a good spot to rest.
Okay.
Well, you were wrong.
Uh oh, there's nowhere to hide in here.
Uh oh.
The music is a bop.
Parlor key?
What other rooms have I missed?
Maybe here?
Uh, this is broken.
This is broken.
The other side.
Where is Patty?
Right!
This is broken.
That was that room.
Where did I miss?
Here?
Is this the parlor?
No.
Was it this one?
No, wait.
I went in here.
This is the other bedroom.
What am I missing?
Yeah, he'll hear me next time.
This was...
Maybe one of these.
I'm so... Am I stupid?
Broken, broken.
Huh?
He'll taste me next time!
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, no.
This is...
Maybe down here?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Hide.
Boom, boom, boom.
He's gonna taste me.
Don't taste me, mister!
You'll like being dead.
I promise.
I do, actually.
Am I safe?
He left a cake.
Can't believe he didn't say, I hear.
I picked up the book.
And, um...
To the library?
I taste...
Cake...
I read...
I taste...
Oh.
Are you winning, Mint?
Um...
No!
No.
No, I'm not.
No, I'm...
I'm not winning.
I feel...
Very... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
This is so icky.
It makes me so claustrophobic.
There's too much particles.
What is that?
What is it like when the air is super still and hasn't been touched in a long time?
Dead air or something?
Can I hide in here?
I'm scared.
Oh, hide.
I can't tell if he can see me in here.
Which is why I'm hiding in the corner.
Playing amnesia now.
I know, right?
I can smell you.
You're in the basement.
Have fun, Mint.
Thanks.
I think.
Exit key.
Now getting out of here is probably going to be the tougher part.
I'm sure of it.
God, this...
makes me feel so gross.
I hate it.
Oh my god.
No way.
That was so close.
Was everything green before?
That was red, wasn't it?
Oh my god.
Wait, is this...
I thought it was...
the guy that needs to stay close to me.
Not the man.
But he can't go through the goop either, right?
Haha!
Yeah!
We're both goop-less!
Oh my god.
He is not giving up.
Oh, chains.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
So if he sees me, he goes like crazy.
He goes sicko mode.
I think.
He starts like running crazy, right?
Oh my god.
Demon noises.
It's so scary.
Okay.
That's why these hallways are some of the scarier ones.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
He's just going sicko mode.
Oh my god.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh, shoot.
I can't tell what he looks like when he makes that noise.
I can't tell.
At all.
Oh, please.
Please end my misery.
Yeah!
Your imagination is scarier either way.
Oh, goodness.
Look at the chains!
P&G chains!
I still cut him in half.
I think I at least gave this guy a candle.
Oh, plus one violence.
Why?
Actually, I just wanted to see if it would happen.
It's not that it was because he was a ghost.
It just was because he was there.
You know?
It wasn't because he was a ghost.
It was because he was my little experiment.
You think that'll hold up in court?
There can only be one ghost?
See, I'll do it to him too!
Haha!
840.
We've been at this for three hours.
Jack-o'-lantern.
Oh, skinny hallway.
What's that sound?
Wait, the axe cause is a bad ending if you use it too much?
No way!
Even if I don't use it on anything?
Even if I just swing it around town?
There's a counter.
Oh, if you kill too many monsters with it.
Well, what about the...
Well, I guess they count as monsters because they were in the specimen book.
Oh, shoot.
No!
I'm thinking Arby's!
I'm not thinking Arby's!
Please!
Okay, I won't kill you anymore!
The deli demon!
He's still after me.
Oh, shoot.
This way?
We got the meat!
Oh my god!
Why is it sometimes...
Does he get too close and that's why it starts flashing?
Meat!
No!
I swear I'll go vegetarian after this!
I swear I'll never eat another burger!
Please!
Just let me go, Arby's!
Oh!
Nope!
The music stopped!
I thought we were good!
Oh, he's still after me.
Still very much after...
Shit!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Wait, did I...
Oh my god!
I thought he was still after me, but he wasn't!
Oh my gosh!
We made it at the best possible room!
I'm scared, Minto!
Don't be scared.
I'll get you through this.
We're just...
I thought it was the...
I didn't realize it was the creepy crawly!
The guy I gotta keep close!
I thought it was the guy I gotta keep close!
Nope, I see them on the ceiling now.
Oh, it's because the ceilings...
I think were high before!
Oh my gosh!
That's so funny.
Yeah, I can't see it from here.
The ceilings were too high.
It's over?
What are you talking about?
It ain't over till the fat lady...
Oh, stamina?
Ah!
Ice cream!
We
made it!
We made it!
Gamers don't look up.
Not gonna lie, completely forgot about that guy.
He was like, Don't forget about me!
Creepy, creepy crawly.
Because we've gotten the goop guy so many times.
I've completely forgotten about that guy.
The one I'm always not prepared for is the...
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait.
I went the wrong way.
I went the wrong way, please!
There he is.
I'm always not prepared for...
the puppet.
This guy though, we can handle.
888!
I like how I realized I went the wrong way as I went the wrong way though.
Minto Gaming.
Have I died to the puppet yet?
No, but now I probably will.
Because I just jinxed myself.
Don't you want to look at the lovely starry night?
Bonk, bonk.
Oh, you didn't even knock that one.
You just...
Yeah, there are two knocks.
I think two knocks.
You can't just knock once and then expect someone to let you in.
You know, you have to knock twice.
Give them a second to...
to answer the door?
They might be, you know, on the toilet?
I need a second, okay?
Do you want a bite?
You want a snack?
You want some ribs?
No, you're good?
He's like, I'm all ribs.
I'm only ribs.
Look at me.
Look at me, Minto.
How am I gonna eat ribs?
I'm all ribs.
I'm sorry.
Can I get too far away from this guy?
He's really needy.
He's really, really needy.
Oh, don't get too far.
Okay, I thought there was gonna be a door right there.
That was my mistake.
Yeah, loop the music.
Loop the music.
You're still here.
And 900!
Oh, that's my footsteps.
Oh my god, I thought he was knocking.
What does that say?
This is the first time I've ever seen someone who knows that it's not over till the fat lady sings quote.
I sometimes say that to people when they say something it's over and they never get it.
Really?
I thought it was a common thing, right?
I thought he was knocking.
Oh my gosh.
We got 100 rooms left, everybody!
No!
Maybe people don't say it anymore, right?
It's just a common phrase.
Is it because we're old?
Boomer phrase?
Definitely used to be common.
Oh, nice.
Straight!
Donk!
Left!
Left, left, left, right!
Oh.
Straight!
Vinto Gaming!
Oh, it's really dark and dreary down here.
First try.
Craziness.
100 more pull-ups!
It's about opera and we don't opera as much as we used to.
I guess that's so true.
She's still going?
I didn't expect to finish the game today, but I don't know.
Maybe I will.
I mean, I'm not...
I mean, I think I will.
I'm at 900.
I might as well, right?
I might as well.
I think...
Unless there's like a secret, like...
You get to 1000, but it's not really...
Oh, gosh.
It's water.
Okay, what's the gimmick here?
Broken.
Oh!
Uh...
Researcher?
Oh, we're in the ocean.
Does anybody have athastasophobia?
Whale015D has died much sooner than I expected while I was away on holiday.
I regret not being here, but I had estimated it would live much longer.
The team that did the autopsy said nothing seemed to be wrong with the lungs, but the stomach had a circular hole about 2 feet in diameter all the way through to the outside of the whale.
This pretty much confirms a parasite is the cause of death.
Oh, not the whale.
This guy seems healthy.
He seems alive and...
whale?
Researcher report 5.
The research facility is now in dire need of more engineers.
We had a whole block that is flooded, and some vital staff are missing.
Uh-oh.
I don't like that.
I don't know what to expect in here.
I'm truly scared.
It's too dark to see.
Okay.
That's never stopped us before, but sure.
We're reading these all out of order.
Yeah, amnesia time.
That's the vibes I'm getting now, too!
No!
Whale015A is still alive, but gets into fits of thrashing and is surfacing more often than natural.
I think there may be a problem with its lungs, but I don't have many tools that would allow me to check it without it dying.
I will have to allow it to die from whatever is causing it and then do an autopsy.
Aww.
Oh.
Whale014D has strange small bite marks.
They appear from another smaller mammal, but the strangest thing about them is their placement.
They are in even rows inside the whale's stomach, all about 5 feet from the bottom of the stomach lining.
Okay, I'm reading these literally all out of order.
100% out of order.
Oh.
It's gonna say, room with nothing in it?
Excerpt 4-132.
And then I watched carelessly as the sea rose above the sky, casting waving shadows over the world.
I saw the silhouettes of creatures both familiar and forgotten.
Suddenly, I found myself falling upwards towards an ocean of darkness.
Lantern?
There's a lantern in here?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
It was too dark to see.
Oh, broken?
Oh!
How am I supposed to do each one?
Oh, turn.
Okay.
Wait, how do I turn it?
Oh!
There we go.
How I've been doing every action.
Is it 4-4-4-4?
Hehehe, spooky!
Read.
Research report number one.
More whales are being shipped to the facility tomorrow.
One for health inspection and two that already died...
Oh, dead for autopsies.
More and more beached whales keep appearing around those islands, and I can't find what is causing it.
I always miss these notes that are on the ground.
The water
Oh, so the excerpt was... what was the number?
A siren?
I would fall for that.
Don't admit that so easily!
Oh gosh.
I'm scared.
The lantern got snuffed out.
Oh my gosh, this is actually amnesia!
No way.
Well, I know.
When something...
is... around.
Well, I know.
I see like a trail.
And can it get me on here?
I'm gonna imagine not.
Because that would be unfair.
Oh gosh.
Eek!
Fish wife.
Oh, there's a note there.
All the staff is gone.
Only I remain.
For no purpose I remain here resisting the call from behind the sealed door.
But I will remain as long as I can.
Don't open that door!
Is it this one?
I sure hope so.
Wait, was there a note in here that I missed?
Did I open the wrong...
Mister, which door?
Can you tell me which one?
Mister!
I think you have to say which door!
Open this one?
Wait a second.
Let's try this real quick.
Don't open that door!
Oh, I got a key.
Oh, and this is probably the key to open the door, isn't it?
Am I gonna open it?
And then like...
Eek!
Oh!
She's beautiful.
Wait a second!
I mean...
Should I...
I think she's topless.
You guys!
You guys, I think she's topless though!
Madam!
You haven't seen her face?
Look at that!
Look at the assets!
I can see them from the fog!
I can see them through the fog!
What are you talking about?
The face?
Come on!
Eating mermaid flesh grants immortality?
If I...go...
Is she gonna stay there?
Broken.
Is this like something trigger?
I'm nervous, you know?
She's still there.
I should look around first.
Okay.
Go closer?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm being a little baby.
I am being a b-b-b-baby.
Oh, she's like camping.
No way.
Oh, she's camping-camping.
She wants you mint.
Wait!
Oh shit.
Oh my
god, oh my god, oh my...
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, she comes in through here?
She's down there?
Did it hurt a lot?
She's a little yandere?
I can't tell what she...oh, I think she came out and then turned around.
Nice.
The water is draining.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, this is the end of this area.
What are you doing, lovely?
Just ask around what's the worst that could happen.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Sure, we'll be fine.
Let's all wait for our health to regenerate.
She was fast.
I like an aggressive lady.
She's feisty, yeah.
Did it leave a hickey?
Yeah, yeah.
Calm down, everybody.
Calm down.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, that was close, that was close, that was close.
She went that way, so I'm gonna go...
this way.
Yes?
She's drawing hearts in the water for me.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, god.
At least she leaves this time.
You know?
You're not you when you're hungry.
Okay, I think I can make it.
9...
13...
Oh, oh, I was gonna say I should just go for it, but I'm glad I didn't.
Does she come back, I wonder?
These last rooms take a long time to clear.
I can imagine.
Does she come back?
Let's give it a second to see.
Are you going to play the DLC?
Probably at some point, but not today.
I would like to at some point, but I think it would be fun.
I don't know where she is.
She sounds pretty far, though.
There she is.
This water doesn't look sanitary.
It's as cleanly as the Seine, which they will be swimming in for the Olympics.
Oh gosh!
I tried to juke her.
Get out of here!
Are you camping me again?
Wait, no.
She turned around.
There she goes.
Love bite.
My first...
time with a mermaid.
There she is.
This is how we communicate.
She draws, you know, stuff in the water.
It's for me to read.
Little love notes.
She kind of looks like a slug.
She's not like...
above the water, you know?
Giving real sluggy energy here.
I didn't know where she was.
Where did she go actually?
I think she went down that way.
Okay.
Oof.
She backtracked.
That was about to go.
Where did she...
I think she went all the way down.
I think we're...
Not good.
Is she going to backtrack here again?
Yep.
Oh.
Half slug, half maid.
A mermaid.
I don't think that's how that works.
I don't think that's where the...
mer part comes...
from.
I might be wrong.
Okay.
So she can now go through under here.
I don't know where she is though.
So...
wrong.
Ah!!
You're absurd.
Hey, a slug girl is just a poor man's slime girl.
I wasn't hating on a slug girl.
I wouldn't discriminate...
monster girls.
I love monster girls.
Thanks for the dono.
She's sending me... she's saying triangle as in like, you know...
This isn't... bad, it's...
Oh my god.
It's not great... triangle.
Actually, she wants to listen to Triangle from Macross right now, that's what she's saying.
Wait.
That's not triangle.
I'm singing the rock song.
Triangle Dreamer.
She's a regular tri...
That's lion, yeah I know!
Wait, how does triangle go again?
Oh kimi wa dare to kisu wo sunu
I don't mind this one so much, it's just a matter of patience, you know?
At least I don't mind it right now.
Murphy brought up a great point.
What about mermaid maids?
And mer... man...
Maids...
Shush...
Um...
Mermaid...
Mermaids...
Are you saying I should get a mermaid outfit?
Oh no, wait, which way do I go?
No, no, I don't know!
Oh.
Uh oh.
I don't know where to go.
Is this a dead end?
I can't tell!
Oh gosh.
Okay, there's a door here!
Hopefully it's okay!
Okay!
Yes!
Gosh.
How long does this last for?
Oh.
Wait, did I just go in a circle?
Oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
I didn't just go in a circle, did I?
No.
I think she's gone.
There it is, the door.
She just went that way.
Don't know where she went.
Oh, there she is.
Go through there.
No.
Go through the...
Go through the grate.
Okay.
Give it a second.
Yup.
Does she always...
Is she just like in a triangle?
Oh.
Okay.
Again, she's sending me signals.
So when she comes back...
Oh.
Wait.
That's different from the pattern that I've just been observing!
Go!
And she's left.
Okay.
She like, comes at me and then turns around.
So it's...
Makes it wait.
Hello!
Just gonna have to go for it?
Madam, please!
She is really quick and they're way less...
I don't even know where the next one is.
There's the door.
Oh!
Oh, my gosh!
Still not quite good, but...
Come on.
You can't go down any lower.
Okay.
Oh, there she is.
This is a low-level tower.
Why didn't they at least let us see the baubles before we...
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I can't even see like the...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Oh...
Could've used a warning!
Holy cow!
I think this is a smaller room.
So it's a little bit trickier.
There she is, going back towards the crate that we need to get to.
No warning, going in raw.
Going in raw.
I was gonna say, I think from here we just run for it!
That one was tough.
Holy cow, how much longer?
924, baby.
75 rooms?
No way.
We have to go through all the rooms?
Like this?
Oh...
I thought... I really thought...
This is... this is actually torture, yeah.
Did she... where'd she go?
Oh.
5 more rooms of this tops, actually?
Or are you... pulling my leg?
I can't tell.
Time sink?
I think the bladder level is more of a time sink than it is fun.
That's the... kind of the vibe I'm...
It's definitely... it is overstated to welcome, I think.
I've done more than enough rooms... of this.
Yeah.
I feel like it's kind of a good thing that it was...
That this is like in the home stretch of the game.
Because otherwise, I feel like this would filter a lot of people.
Like if... imagine if this was in like 300, I think I would have been like, nah, I think I'm good.
But at this point, you're so far in, you don't even... you're like, well...
I've made it this far, I can't just quit.
So it ends up becoming like a sunk cost fallacy.
I feel like so close, but so far.
Like I feel like any... any room... the next room will surely be it, you know?
Like you can't do this... you can't do this the whole... for 75 more rooms.
That'd be craziness.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please, let me out of this.
Let me out of this hellscape.
Bring me back to Arby's.
Oh, okay.
This is a dead end.
Of course it is.
I need a break.
I'm not breaking up with you.
It's you.
It's not... I mean, it's me.
It's not you.
It's you, just a little bit.
But I just... I just need a bit of a break, please.
Yeah, go in there.
There's so much going on in there.
At some point, I'm just... I'm just going for it.
I'm like, I can't even be bothered.
Please.
Please, please put me out of my misery.
Girlfriend.
Maybe 9.30 will be the last of it.
I sure hope so.
Surely by 9.30.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I'm getting a little braver with it.
Actually, I don't know if it's bravery or impatience.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh, that was close.
Thank you.
Welcome to membership.
No.
Girlfriend.
That was so close.
Oh gosh.
Yikes.
It's okay, she's leaving.
She wants you so bad.
Collegian.
Collegian, thank you so much for the birthday.
Oh.
I got it.
Achievement marathon.
Just keep moving.
I'm trying.
Thank you so much.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
Thank you.
You did a 50 earlier.
Thank you so much.
Just keep moving.
Says the game.
I'm just .
It's like a mosquito.
You know.
I'm just too tasty.
I'm too tasty.
That was so scary.
Behind me.
Ch
Choco -mint flavored.
There she go.
A poacher.
And there I go.
Oh my god.
I just want to have a word with the devs.
I just want to have a word with the devs, please.
There is at some point when something becomes too much.
It's not scary anymore.
It's just frustrating.
Literally like every... I feel like every indie horror game does this.
At some point, you know?
Every horror indie horror game has a part where it's just...
It has overstayed its welcome!
This section is... I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm trying to make it entertaining.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let's wait for her to turn around.
Still made you jump?
Yeah, because she attacked me.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
According to WikiMermaid...
Ending... End to N30!
No...
What?
It has to be... maybe...
N30...
9...
I said N as if like...
Because, you know, 9 starts with an N.
940.
Okay, 940.
You're the cutest ghostmate.
Oh, stop it.
Okay, how many ghostmates do you actually know, though?
Have you guys seen the latest Tantoquare pack?
Have you seen...
If you have not seen the latest Tantoquare pack...
I'm kind of just like...
I'm like side-eyeing it a little bit.
Because it's literally free!
Wait, but the water went down!
There's more!
Tantoquare is a...
Is a...
A made card game.
940, right?
Let's let... I'm gonna let my...
Me heal again, just in case.
Looks like an old Edo game with that art style.
Isn't that the best, though?
Love...
Please, please, please, please.
Oh my god, I didn't realize she was right there.
No, no, no, no.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Why does it keep going?
I'm gonna look at the new expansion pack.
I love Tantoquare.
Yeah.
I forgot how to play this game now.
I'm not gonna lie.
We were in there for so long, I forgot how to play normally.
Oh my gosh.
It's the brain.
Freedom!
Oh my gosh.
Mr. Obese, thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
But I'm kind of more nervous now because at least with...
At least with the mermaid, it was predictable, you know what I mean?
Now I'm just like, what's gonna happen?
But just 50 left.
I would love a save right now.
I know, right?
Gosh.
Oh, gosh.
I'm our wispy friend.
Oh!
We're back here.
Specimen.
Did we do 12 before?
Oh, the mansion.
That's right.
Oh yeah, we went in here.
Wait, so there's nothing else?
There's...
They don't even have a thing on the mermaid.
Right?
Huh.
This one...
What is this one?
Have I seen this one?
I have no idea.
She's just visiting.
Dang it.
Oops.
There we go.
Should be specimen 13.
No, there isn't one.
I don't know which one it is.
Wait.
This guy!
I don't like the sound he makes.
I really don't like the sound he makes.
It's so scary.
Just some guy.
Yeah, he can smell me.
He can hear me.
He can see me.
He can see...
Oh my gosh.
Sniffle Mambo.
He says, where are you?
I don't know.
Is that what he's doing?
He's so obsessed with me!
Oh, I think we made it through.
9.69!
A different kind of room.
Really threw me off for a second.
Oh, goodness gracious.
We're so close.
What is this?
New music?
Horror of a dude with at least three senses.
He'll never get the fifth sense.
He'll never...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, it's this guy.
Okay.
I forgot he busts down the door.
Oh, you're too weak to deal with the bridge?
Knock, knock.
What was I gonna say?
Oh, yeah.
He'll never reach the last one, which is touch.
Okay.
20 left!
Or taste.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
He'll never taste me alive!
Tom and Jerry has reaction!
Shut up!
Oh, my God.
What was that?
What was that on the... on the right side?
I don't even want to know.
She really mastered the goofy impression.
What impression?
Are you calling me goofy?
Let's go to the left this time.
8!
7!
6!
5!
Why is it...
GL Labs!
Wait, why is it giving me a save of 5 left?
Keep that blood pumping!
Wait!
5 more, but why do we have a save?
I'm scared!
This seems ominous.
Extremely so.
But we saved!
So I feel a little less... bad.
Here we go.
What do you mean by that?
I don't know what to expect at all.
Especially considering the fact that...
That's the halfway point.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Nope.
I'm scared when you guys say that!
3?
2?
What's gonna happen?
Go towards the light!
What light?
Literally?
Oh, axe!
I forgot I had it!
Yippee!
The world is so much cuter than I thought it would be!
I can't go around the building.
Oh my gosh, window XP!
Bye bye!
Oh, I don't know if I'm trapped in here.
Is that me?
Portal moment?
You made it.
Congratulations.
I guess.
Uh, well...
So now you must pass one final test.
Prove your...
...cruelty to the door.
What's that sound?
Oh!
Or something!
I have no stamina.
Okay.
I still have the axe.
731?
731.
What the hell was that?
Sorry.
Is this your room?
Oh, it's this guy!
Oh!
What are you gonna do?
You won't take me!
Come down here!
You...
You coward!
Bloody, bloody!
Yeah,
I can't jump.
Use the BFG.
How am I
supposed to get him?
He's like squirming.
He's doing hands.
He's getting handsy with me.
Oh!
Oh, that one hurt me.
Ouch.
Oh, can I, um, maybe...
Oh,
nice!
Take that!
Here we go.
Yeah!
What's happening?
Uh-oh.
What does
it take to kill this guy?
Yeah.
Handsy.
Handsy bastard!
Oh!
I don't think I can reflect this one.
I'm assuming.
I'm assuming I cannot reflect that one.
But I will try.
This one!
Now there's probably gonna be like five guys!
Four guys!
Close enough!
Ouchie, ouchie.
Okay, this one probably I can't reflect then, right?
Yeah.
Oh, when it's red!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I get it.
Cool.
It's
cool when it's red, right?
Only when it's not red?
Damn!
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, I have to be careful with this one, though.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no!
No!
I missed my chance!
Oh!
No!
That's me.
That's me right now.
Okay.
These guys.
That would help if I actually could hit them.
Oh, please.
Hit
it when it's red.
It's fine.
Oh!
I didn't eat it.
Me too.
Yippee!
Silence!
Well, you died.
In a pretty tragic way, too.
I did?
Just tragic enough for you to become a ghost.
Good job, by the way, making it this far.
So, buckle up, soldier.
Because now, I finally think we have enough troops to invade.
I'm...
Where are we going?
Oh!
Are we invading heaven?
What are we invading?
I...
I died after all that!
The time has come, my loyal troops.
Tell us,
will we be disregarded and ignored?
For now, we are the most feared army in the world.
MSF!
Did you really think it was going to end seriously?
What do you mean, you'll
win?
I can...
I can speed it up.
Sorry.
Sorry, developers.
I can...
Ahahaha!
That's so evil!
Wow!
There's a bunch...
There's a couple names in here that I recognize.
That's so silly.
Aw...
Vinesauce!
Matara has been talking to that guy.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Shoutouts...
Shoutouts to vinesauce.
Haha!
Bukkake!
If you're too violent and break things with the axe too much, instead of the ghost ending, you become a specimen yourself.
Ah, I see, I see.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted!
Funny ghost maid?
No!
No longer will we be called funny!
Or cute!
We will invade!
It's funny because when Matara was just like, Oh yeah, I collabed with a guy named Vinesauce the other day.
Like the first time she collabed with him, I was just like, What?
You collabed with Vinny?
She was like, yeah, I don't know who that is.
And I was like, this is...
Are we in a parallel universe?
Where I know who someone is and you don't know who someone is?
That was funny.
Felt like that too.
I was like, what?
I feel like Matara is lying.
She should know who Vinny...
No, she said she didn't know.
But I was like, you know every Twitch person.
GG, funny and cute ghost.
No!
No longer will we be called funny or cute!
We are...
We are the ghost revolution!
This music...
Okay, hold on.
What was a...
Was it under options?
That the music was kinda chill?
Yeah.
I like the music here.
Can't wait to see you lead the ghost revolution.
Fun game, even if the water level overstayed its welcome.
Yeah, no, still really fun.
Oh my gosh, frog, please, your wallet.
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Are you okay?
Your wallet though.
Congrats on beating the game, funny and cute ghost.
No, stop!
Funny?
Cute?
You got the wrong guy.
I don't think I've ever been funny and cute in my life.
I'm just clowning around.
What does crowd control do?
What's crowd control?
Wait, in the...
Oh, crowd control.
I see it.
That's a great question.
Disconnected.
Crowd control allows twitch.tv viewers to influence the game while broadcasting.
Why is it only twitch.tv?
Note that crowd control is less effective in Karamari Hospital and the Dollhouse.
Only twi...
This is the only good thing about twitch.
Is you can do silly things like that.
You can...
There's so many things, ways to connect with your chat and stuff.
Common YouTube L.
But don't worry.
I don't ever have plans on streaming on twitch.
If you were just like...
Oh, she's getting more and more convinced.
First it's marbles.
Now it's...
Crowd control.
No, no.
Don't worry.
I don't want to stream on twitch.
Thank God for that.
Minto is no longer a funny and cute ghost from this day on.
It's been real, y'all.
No.
Good stream gave me lots of fun.
I have lots of ideas for art.
Especially art involving slime girls and mint.
Wait, your name.
I'm...
Cute Sans Frontiers.
You can encounter the dead guy early if you're AFK for too long or in an endless hallway.
Oh.
Then what do you do with him?
Oh, does he just kill you?
From what I understand, this game is about a ghost maid who cleans up her delinquent master's mansion, gets lost in sewers, somehow becomes even stinkier.
Congrats on the win, Minto.
I am very curious.
I know...
Hold on.
We'll come back to the nice music in a second.
Instead of this almost penis music.
Yeah.
The Karamari Hospital.
Unlock the secrets of the Stranger Banner Hospital.
And then the dollhouse.
And then you can...
Eventually, you can build your own mansion.
That seems so fun.
This one seems like for an insane person, actually.
Endless mode seems like...
I don't know.
If you actually are insane.
This is so relaxing.
Even when you...
Even when you and Twitch chat, folks don't believe it.
I know.
It's so funny.
Gosh.
This music is so nice.
I wish I had this as like a normal BGM.
I know we're not there yet, but do you have any spooky memories?
Do you have any plans for October?
Actually.
Yes.
Well, first off, my birthday is in October.
October 1st, everybody.
Endless mode.
Eventually, you get multiple monsters at once.
It's actually pretty interesting.
Again, for insane people.
And then not 31st.
No, no.
I died on October 1st.
Not the 31st.
I say it's my birthday.
It's my death day.
Birth is a ghost.
So.
Mine is October 20th.
October twinsies.
What do you want for your birthday, Minto?
Well, we still have plenty of time.
I know what I want.
I'm gonna hope for it.
I'm gonna build my own mansion with slime girls and maids.
You know what?
Forget the mansion.
Wait, you forgot the blackjack.
Dude, space.
I'm blackjack.
Blackjack!
Jack!
Happy birthday.
Thanks, Mary Faye!
So, on my birthday...
October 1st is my 06th birthday.
What does that mean?
When you, when you...
You were, you...
Fetus?
Glad you liked the game.
The dev has made a lot of other good games like Lost in Viva...
Oh!
And Lunacid, if you have an itch for more.
Wait, I've heard of Lost in Vivo before.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, there's locked achievements too.
Oh, these are like Caramari...
The Caramari...
The Calamari Hospital.
Wait, if I go to their store page...
Oh, sorry, you can hear it.
Lost in Vivo...
Wait.
Is it not on...
Steam?
Caramari Hospital.
Catamari Damacy.
Lunacid is inspired by proto Dark Souls games.
Marukami!
Thanks for the ice cream.
It's on Steam.
Wait, Lost in...
Why wasn't it showing up for me?
Oh, sorry, you can hear it.
A horror game about claustrophobia.
Whoa!
I feel like...
I feel like maybe I've seen a Let's Play of this or something.
Or maybe I'm crazy.
Eww!
Looks icky.
I am very much of the mindset where...
Like I said earlier, I'm pretty picky about my horror game tastes.
I typically like more...
Fatal Frame...
Style...
I'm not a huge fan of like...
Monsters?
Because they don't really scare me.
Typically, you know?
Well...
What's not...
What's not a spam, please?
But uh...
You like ghosts.
I love ghosts!
You like when you can't fight back?
I guess so, maybe.
Hmm...
I don't think it's that it's fighting back.
I just like...
I just think it scares me more.
And...
I like things that scare me.
Even though they scare me.
Oh, I've played a little bit of Siren before.
Oh, Kuon!
I've never played...
I haven't played that one actually.
Or wait...
Kuon...
Jewel?
Kuon is a game though, isn't it?
What about Ghostbusters?
Keck W.
Hahaha!
Those guys are...
Those guys are phonies.
Yeah, Kuon...
I don't think I ever had it.
Calling!
Yes, I loved calling!
I loved calling.
System Shock 2 has ghosts in it.
What about System Shock 1?
What?
A cheat horror too?
Like live stream?
Yes!
Yeah...
I just...
I love...
I like horror more like that.
But it's also not the popular kind of horror, I think.
I think horror like...
Monster horror, Resident Evil type horror and stuff is more popular.
So, unfortunately...
Because more people are just like...
Or like, you know...
Like...
Oh, there's a serial killer stalking ya.
Stuff like that is more popular.
This game's DLC would be fun for Halloween lead up.
You know what?
That's a great idea.
It's kind of far from me playing it.
Like, you know...
I'm finishing it...
The game in July.
But...
It would be fun to...
To...
Play the DLC and stuff.
Maybe in...
In Halloween.
I'll add it to my calendar.
So I don't forget.
Calendar...
We'll do it...
There.
Spooky...
Spooky's Mansion DLC.
Calamari...
How...
Can I do both?
Do you think I can do both DLCs in one stream?
Calamari...
Hospital...
And...
Dollhouse.
Or are they...
Are they pretty long?
I think.
It's possible.
Are you going to play the Silent Hill 2 remake on stream?
I think I will.
Even though I'm very...
I'm hesitant.
It's Bloober Team.
So I'm hesitant.
And...
Apparently the new Nintendo game is also Bloober Team.
The M.E.O.
I'm nervous.
I'm not a big fan of Bloober Team.
Have you played Signalist?
I have!
I really like Signalist.
It was pretty spooky too.
Corral!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
M.E.O.
Isn't Bloober?
I thought...
I thought people figured out it was.
I saw a source say it could not be Bloober.
Have you played Yomawari?
Yes.
Before I went to heaven, actually, I played Yomawari.
But...
I haven't played Yomawari 2.
But I have a little bit of trauma from Yomawari.
Trauma.
Karateka, you remember.
I have a little bit of trauma from the final boss of Yomawari.
You couldn't beat it?
No, I did.
Just with...
A lot...
Of swearing.
Lorekeeper, welcome!
Look up old game cosmo...
Cosmo...
Cosmetic...
Cosmetology...
Cosmology of Kyoto.
From...
From Soft's old game, Kuon.
Like I said, I am familiar with Kuon.
Just a little bit.
But Cosmology of Kyoto...
This one I've never heard of before.
1993.
Never heard this one before.
Is it a... woah!
Woah!
Interesting.
Is it... what?
Is it like a visual novel?
What is this?
A visual mindscape of old Japan.
This looks really interesting.
I have no idea...
what the gameplay... oh my gosh!
Woah!
Sorry, I'm looking at google image googles.
Images...
Have you played the Watson Scott test?
It's a personality test game.
It could show your IP address.
Oh, I don't want that to happen.
But I haven't played it.
You know, Alan Wake is pretty spooky.
I have Alan Wake!
I did buy it.
And I got my Epic Games account back.
So...
I could play it.
Soma...
Oh, a lot of people have been...
Or rather...
I always see Soma recommended.
Glad to be here with me for a month.
Ah!
Erin, thank you!
Thanks for a month!
Ju-on the grudge on the Wii U.
I...
Yes.
When someone said Kuon earlier, I was just like...
Wait, the Ju-on grudge game for the Wii.
FMV games.
Like Seventh Guester.
Oh, I know...
I don't know Seventh Guest.
The Seventh Guest.
But I do know Phantasmagoria.
You guys are always giving such interesting...
Recommendations.
Deadly Premonition.
I have that also on my list.
Probably will do it...
Probably sometime in August.
I want to play it.
Just nine more months.
Until what?
Until what, Haru?
Scarlet Hollow.
It's a spooky visual novel.
Same team that made Slay the Princess.
No way, really!
I love Slay the Princess.
Scarlet...
Hollow.
I love how this has suddenly turned into like a... game recommendation corner.
Ooh, it's kinda creepy.
I'll let you know.
I think I'll play Faith during October as well.
Though I've played them before, is that okay?
Lost in Vivo... Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
We were just talking about that, random.
Faith is great!
It's okay?
If I play it again?
I thought you said fate.
No, Faith!
Minto, you already went through the entire game?
I have!
I'm a gamer.
I went through it, baby.
Mortis.
I'll add that to October.
Faith Trilogy.
I don't think I'll be able to do all of three.
Maybe the same day, but...
Great collab game.
Oh, yes!
Actually, Matara and I keep trying to do a Deep Rock Galactic collab.
Maybe with Henya or something.
Corpse Party.
I love Corpse Party.
Rock and Stone.
They're making a new chapter for Faith?
No way, really?
Erdorf?
I want to work with that guy.
Minto game.
Be kind of crazy.
Did someone say Rock and Stone?
Rock and Stone!
I haven't played...
I saw actually at AX, they had several areas where you could play...
Corpse Party 2.
But like...
It's in 3D.
I don't know how to feel about it.
But also, there was a Corpse Party 2 already.
It was like set in a hospital.
I never played it.
I only played...
I used to...
I loved...
I think her name was Naho from Corpse Party.
There's one line though.
Yeah, Naho.
I really loved her.
I even cosplayed her at one point.
But...
Um...
There's one line.
If you know Corpse Party, you know the famous...
The infamous line.
But I played...
Regular Corpse Party and then I played...
What?
Book of Shadows?
I didn't play...
The Sachiko's birthday one.
The butter!
Rochebug knows.
Rowlet knows.
Butter.
The pooper.
Doki talked a lot about Corpse Party on stream before.
Wait, has she played it?
I'll have to ask her.
I didn't think she liked horror.
But I guess it's...
I don't know.
It's not scary but the atmosphere is very, very creepy.
The sound design in the game is very, very good I think.
There's one ending that you can get.
Like one death ending where...
Where...
You...
Uh...
You die.
You get buried alive.
And like it just actually makes me choke.
Because it's so...
It's so...
The sound design is so good.
The voice actors are so good.
Hungry ghosts for the PS2 could be interesting.
Hungry ghosts.
Why does this look older than a PS2 game?
It's only in Japanese.
Nihongo only.
Looks maybe to be the case.
I think I have...
I have so many games though.
I'll ask for recommendation.
If you want to leave a recommendation in the comments or something.
For me to...
What's the word?
Go over in the future.
Then, you know...
That would be the best.
Because otherwise I'll forget.
Yume Nikki.
I love Yume Nikki though.
Yeah, maybe.
There's like the 3D Yume Nikki but it's not the same, right?
Night Trap.
Very infamous FMV.
That more or less led to the...
ESRB is creation?
Really?
Wait, I have heard of Night Trap though.
Never mind, just kidding.
Thank you for defending Patamon.
I have heard of Night Trap, but I've not played Night Trap.
There was that one game that came out just a couple years ago.
At Dead of Night, I think it was called.
It's not exactly FMV.
Or maybe... does it count?
Actually, I don't know.
But I... I've always...
It's... It's... It's...
Like, I want to play it, but I think I would actually be too stressed for it.
Oh, Dot Flo... Oh my god, Dot Flo.
I have... I have not heard of that game.
In so long.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Dot Flo.
I completely forgot about Dot Flo until just now.
Wow.
Night Trap requires... requires a guide.
Night Trap is so cheesy.
It looks like...
It looks like a...
80s, you know, like... what's the word?
Like an 80s slasher.
Campy horror.
I love that though.
What was it released on?
Is it Mega... Mega CD?
Sega CD, wow.
There is no gore though.
Oh.
Little goody-two-shoes.
Oh yes, I've seen... I've heard a lot of really good things about that.
Or rather...
The animation and everything.
Looks so awesome.
I remember a while back you were talking about maybe...
only being around till the end of the summer.
Now we're here discussing October plans.
Feels nice.
It's good to have you around.
Thank you, SilverAid.
Thank you!
Yeah.
I think...
Hmm...
I don't know what to... how to...
I think like...
I...
Had...
Well...
I... initially was just like...
Coming back...
I wasn't sure... you know...
Uh...
But...
Um...
I've talked with a lot of people.
Like a lot, a lot, a lot of people.
And it's kind of...
You know, at first I was like...
Unsure...
Of what direction to go and... and stuff.
But...
You know...
Through a bunch of people's advice and...
Um...
I've...
My...
Uh...
Experiences?
I...
...
I felt like maybe I should...
Hmm....
Go differently from my original plan...
That I was thinking.
Um...
So I'm still...
Even now...
Like...
Unsure if I'm even...
Doing the right thing...
I guess...
Hahaha...
Um...
Everything is so confusing.
I'm always just like, why can't things be normal?
But I do really love streaming.
And if you guys will still have me...
Then you know, I can be around.
I don't know for how much longer, but...
For the...
For the future...
I don't even know how to say it.
What is considered long-term anyway?
Foreseeable future?
Yeah!
50 years.
Okay.
It's just all still...
Confusing to me.
Everything.
But...
Yeah, I'm always thinking about it like every day.
I'm like...
Minto's brain goes...
But I'm doing my best.
So...
Thanks for supporting me!
Thanks for hanging out with me tonight.
Thanks for watching me go through 1,000 rooms of craziness.
Actual 1,000 rooms of craziness.
Stream from the nursing home if you have to.
Six seasons and a movie!
Community never came back!
Thank you for being here to entertain us.
We're lucky to have you here.
Thanks, Sean.
Welcome to membership!
Never brought up, but I want a second Soma.
The story has stuck to me more than almost any other game I've ever played.
It's not just scary.
It's haunting.
It keeps haunting you after you finish.
Okay, I'll add it to our October.
I don't want to...
I'm like...
I'm always in the mood to play spooky horror.
Try Princess, thank you!
You're always in the mood to play more horror, but I'm like...
Maybe I should start gathering stuff for October.
Spooky, spooky month.
Soma.
Is that a game I can...
Let's see, how long to be...
Soma.
As long as you're happy, we'll be happy.
We'll be especially happy for however long you keep streaming.
Thank you.
A third Soma.
Oh, nine hours?
It's probably like what...
Oh wait, it took me about six...
No, probably like two to three streams.
I'm not gonna say your name.
Your name is Please!
Oh, you have such nice manners!
You have such nice manners.
What's most difficult for me right now is there's so many games that I want to play that are kind of...
Kind of...
Long?
I'm trying not to be like...
Okay, let's play every long game at once!
So it's nice to get some games in like this kind of that I can do in one stream.
I try to balance it.
Like having, you know, obviously I'm doing Metal Gear.
But then I have like also Eternal Darkness.
And then I do some other in-between stuff as well.
It's like what Gray Fox says.
Just keep fighting for what you believe in and we'll be there to support and laugh with you.
Thanks so much for caring.
I was a hardcore Lurker Vaude Watcher, so I'm glad you're back, Minto.
I decided I didn't want to miss out this time.
And your streams are the most fun, period!
Mint's cute.
I'm excited for all that's next.
What?
No way!
You stopped being a Lurker because I came back?
Thank you!
But that's not to say also if you Lurk, you know, that you have to stop lurking.
I appreciate everybody who watches at all.
Even you, Vaude Watcher.
I don't even know if a Vaude Watcher would still be listening.
But, you know, Lurkers, still a Lurker.
Not anymore!
I see you.
Not so common sense.
But, you know, if you, if you, if you, if you've been watching since I first debuted, if you came in between heaven, if you came after heaven, if you lurk, if you chat all day every day, if you spam in my chat, if you have weird names like, please pee on me,
Mint Phantom, if you, if you have, if you, I don't know, where was I going?
Anyways, I appreciate you guys.
Mint Appreciation Tax.
Boopie!
You changed your profile picture.
What is that?
Bustin.
She loves us.
I'm a newer subscriber.
I'll be happy to stick around for as long as you need your fans.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Yeah, if you came, if you started watching after I came back, yeah.
Um, Matara and I kind of covered, talked about this, I think in the Patreon episode.
But someone asked a question on Patreon, of the podcast Patreon.
They were like, when do I become a Wisp or a or a Momo?
Since Matara's fanbase is called Momos.
They were like, when do you become a Wisp or a Momo?
Is it when you donate?
Is it when you chat?
Is it when you...
Oh my gosh, frog.
Thank you for the pig!
And I was like...
It's like, no!
They were like, were you a Mo...
Do you have to be a Momo from day one?
It's like, no!
I joined a softball team.
I'm baseball field now!
Hahaha!
When you sacrifice your soul.
Pretty much.
As soon as you take a step in here and allow me to absorb a little bit of your life energy, you're basically a Wisp.
Whoever that was, I was baseball field too.
We love Minto!
Thank you!
Kyle!
Welcome!
Welcome back!
Was also a lurker vodwatcher until your comeback.
Didn't want to miss out this time either.
No way!
That's so crazy.
That's so so crazy.
But again, you know, just being here.
You don't miss now.
I think.
Pyrobot!
I'm a gift!
But yeah, you know, I'm just...
Usually lurk.
I'm just watching you while farming runes.
Hahaha!
Keep farming them runes.
So if our official fan name is Wisp, I would like to propose we canonize the name Pissy Wispy.
V Toad!
Minto?
Majority vote.
No, this is not democracy!
No!
That was bad posting, Oshijito.
Yeah, let's just ignore that and keep on keeping on.
Oh, I just... Sorry, I did not see you.
Phantom Inc.
Thanks for the gifted membership!
Sorry if I missed donos and stuff while I was playing because sometimes it was hard to...
hard to re-chat and also avoid all of these guys.
If you Vetoed, does that make you a Peace Walker?
Oh wait, if you're Vetoed, does that make you a Peace Walker?
I like it.
She hates us.
Frogbert?
Frogbert is not Vetoed.
He is Webtoed.
Oh my god, he's chronically online.
He's chronically on the World Wide Webtoed.
Oh my gosh, that's what, you know, that's what like a feet...
a feet...
a frog feet wiki would be called.
Webtoes.
Hey cutie.
Hey meaches fries.
Your name is cut off, but is it still Mint Slice?
Someone reboot the mage you stuck on re...
feet?
Very glad to get to see you stream your...
and enjoy yourself.
For however long that works for you.
Listening to you up here or the podcast is a pleasure.
Miss Mint Fan Toilet.
That might be the worst nickname ever to come out.
That might be actually...
the worstest nickname anybody could have given that to me.
Can you keep saying feet?
Feet, feet, feet.
Feet, feet, feet, feet, feet.
Feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet.
Feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet.
Feet.
Oh my gosh!
I just realized the time!
I'm gonna go to sleep now.
I'm gonna go to bed!
Thank you guys again for joining me for...
almost five hours of...
Why did I have to zoom in on the face?
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
I hope you guys have fun.
I hope you guys have a nice... night?
Morning?
Afternoon?
Whatever time it is.
For you!
Oh, wait!
Ashes, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Only just started interacting because I'm very shy despite watching you since debut.
Don't worry, me too.
If you think you're shy, I'm more shy.
Thank you for always having such a kind space.
Ever since you came back, I've met other Wisps.
Went to my first concert.
And even got my first penlight.
Thanks for being around me.
Oh my gosh!
We have a danger!
Thank you!
Do we have to duke it out?
No.
Wait.
Maybe?
If you want.
Yulian, I don't know if yours will show up because it might be...
It might be buried.
You've done so much these past three months.
So proud of you.
It's okay to take your time figuring things out.
No need to rush.
As long as you're happy doing what you want.
We're happy and we'll support whatever direction you want to go.
Love you, Minto.
Thank you!
First penlight.
That's always so exciting.
Thanks.
That's the one I just read.
Hey Mint, your double finger gun is pretty good.
Thank you!
George.
Good night, Minto.
I look forward to seeing you.
I'm Otaku-tan.
Thank you!
See you there.
Actually, it's funny you bring up the double finger guns.
Because you may enjoy a new emote coming out.
And that's all.
I will say...
Thank you everybody for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
I really, really, really, really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
And yeah, have a good day.
Have a good night.
Have a good day!
And I'll see you guys next time!
Bye-bye!
Good night!
I forgot to say Otu Minto.
Have a good night.
Good night!
Have a good night everyone!
Good night everyone!
You guys!
prior thing today that allowed me to move my hands 3D!
Yup~~